first of all I want to congratulate you
on your bravery for clicking on such a
long video I recently streamed the 2022
Autumn marathon on leechas it's one of
the largest tournaments of the Year this
tournament attracted over 23 000 players
and is a 24-hour Blitz tournament I
streamed almost 12 hours of it across
two different streams I played over 100
games and I'm time stamping every single
game in the video description with my
opponent's name reading and uh the
opening as well a special thanks to
traveler uh viewer at my twitch chat who
built an amazing website to automate all
the time stamping uh saved a lot of time
on my end and uh yeah a lot happened
throughout this tournament as you'll see
I played a handful of cheaters all of
which actually got banned pretty quickly
by leeches I also want to mention that I
received my large largest one-time
viewer donation from Anonymous donor
during the stream huge thank you to the
uh just super generous supporter that
made just a massive donation it does
make a big difference in helping support
the content I am truly grateful for it
if you're watching this uh shortly after
the video is released I might be taking
a small break from posting in the next
few days I have some traveling coming up
I'm going to Toronto at the end of
October for the global chess
championships
um so it's gonna be hard to post while
traveling but hopefully there will be
content opportunities there and one last
thing before we get to the chess I want
to give a big thank you to Audible for
sponsoring today's video and for this ad
read I will be switching to a slightly
different location so I want to give a
big thank you to Audible for sponsoring
today's video now you can probably tell
that I'm not in my natural habitats but
I'm immersing myself in nature and this
is one of my favorite places to come and
take a walk and listen to a great
audiobook on Audible while watching the
Ducks and these hopefully they don't
attack me
I've been using Audible for years now
long before they sponsor my content and
I'm really into the business and
self-development genre and it's one of
the main ways I keep learning and get
inspired these days
and one audiobook I've been listening to
recently that I've really been enjoying
is called how to think like a monk by
Jay Shetty and it's all about finding
your inner peace and purpose and
shifting your mindset from a monkey mind
to a monk mind and it's already brought
a lot of value to me I think it can
bring a lot of value to you as well so
if you want to try Audible for free for
30 days and get any audiobook of your
choice including think like a monk I do
have a special offer for my viewers you
can click the link in the video
description audible.com I am Rosen or
text iron Rosen to 500 500 and thanks
again to Audible for sponsoring this
video now let's get back to some chess
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
uh
uh let me know in the comments what your
favorite game is also don't forget to
subscribe it does help the channel I'm
trying to break
500 90 000 subscribers and then
hopefully 600 000 subscribers before the
end of the year
so here we have the first game playing a
mar 2012
uh I mean god let's start with a
Stafford right maybe
please take my Pawn
though okay still allowing some
transposition
okay we'll have a symmetrical Italian
[Music]
yeah each three is um it's a move it's a
safe move it prevents this
I think I'll go for Knight A5
easy way to get the bishop error
if Bishop B5 I have C6 Bishop A4 B5
I'll take right away
we might see Bishop E3
yeah and now it's a question like I can
play this move I can take
I think taking makes sense
I'm just castling
we have a very kind of compositional
game to start off
rookie eight
yeah going for D5
no need to waste any more time
will this stream be four hours long
well it's not going to be 20 hours long
um I think four hours is a reasonable
estimate maybe a little bit less
if I had to guess maybe between two and
three
but we'll see
so D4 is a move
um
yeah D4 is very forcing because like
takes takes Knight has to move Knight B1
not sure if I want that
maybe something like this first
300 today thanks for the instructional
content thank you keep it up
barbecues
happy eight months
well hello
oh hello bumpy face Mac welcome back
and actress happy 19 months good luck in
the wait for it tournament
oh yeah
we we love how the TTS pronounces
tournament
I want to play this and then the triple
Fork but then Queen F2
I probably shouldn't overthink this
um I mean white has a simple plan though
I'm trying to figure out what my plan is
so maybe I should take a little bit of
time
thank you
like I want to develop my queen should
probably be on C7
sprinkler goes tstsp
yeah there's a limit to the amount of
CSS you can put for TCS
uh thanks for trying to wake me up
though I'm gonna need as much
stimulation as possible this stream
foreign
the green tea only does so much
welcome back to Andrew thank you on the
rocks
for the first time Prime sub
um
yeah Queen B4 was an idea
I think I'll play Queen B4
you're pressuring the pawn
I've got work in the morning so can't
watch long but hope the stream goes well
it's going well so far
I haven't fallen asleep yet
I haven't blundered any material yet
we'll see how long I can keep this up
for
yeah so I finally can play Bishop E6
because the pawn was no longer attacked
and do you have more friends that are
older than you or younger than you
um
probably older
but it might be close
when I was younger I definitely had a
lot of older friends Eric congrats on
longest appearance on lay Friedman
podcast without speaking your Wikipedia
my pleasure was on his computer like the
whole second half of Levy's episode warm
greetings
oh with you looking me up
wait no way I I saw that uh I was
mentioned at some point
something about Chess boxing
and Levy was telling a story about me on
the podcast too
something about wedding photos
but I didn't realize he had my Wiki Up
that's great that my Wiki um wasn't
deleted
there is a period a few years ago when
my Wiki kept getting deleted because
Wiki admins were arguing that I wasn't
notable enough
and then I think a bunch of people
argued back
okay there's tension between the Rooks
we could trade everything
I don't think white really
wanted to be so cruel to the knights
what to do here in G6 hey Eric
congratual improvements until my
subiversary smirking face
hey keep it up hey it's Brad what's up
Brad
also thank you Joe Samu
appreciate the 1000 bits
oh Queen D2 is an idea
um
I could take right away
there's this move
I should not be moving so slowly I just
don't know what to do I'll play A5
so Queen D3 we can trade
oh Queen d1's coming
okay we can still trade
maybe A4
so the b-pawn is pinned in the night
something about deja vu Target
also quack
at first I thought that might be jimano
but
that would have been a new message for
jimano welcome back love HS
uh before B4 looks nice
might be one coming
it's really close to winning material
I'll play this move so I'm throwing A3
The Simple Plan is now just to promote
the a pawn
if takes I can play Bishop C4
yeah there's really not a great
penetration square like Rook D6 is
possible but
that's possible
hmm
okay I do another C5
there's a funny line like Rook D6 Bishop
D5
and there we go
The Rook is now hugged by my pieces
all these pieces hugging The Rook
even though only one of these arrows is
a legal move
this is a the most important Arrow
die plunder
I don't think I've blundered
it's still tricky though
um let's play this
this is my first game I've ever not like
flag
I'm on the exchange now I'm just down
about 10 seconds
okay Knight wants to travel
okay Rick wants a skewer
yeah there's no way to defend
both the knights
there's one check
um
oh it's resisting
okay
let's go
the U1 clutch Spork for the gifted sub
from earlier oh thank you Samsonite for
the five gifted
I appreciate that
okay that was the first game
what was uh what was fing duster saying
about Lex Friedman
oh just about the Wiki page another game
started oh
okay I almost uh
forgot about another game starting
um
someone wanted a Dutch earlier
there's usually a few people that want
to touch so
hopefully some people are satisfied
um there's a few different dutches I can
play there's classical there's Leningrad
there's stone wall
I think I'll play Leningrad
like Leningrad has a pretty simple plan
speaks for itself
literally with text to speech welcome
back Knight C8
now I'm trying to make the Dutch speak
for itself
so far these are all like very typical
Dutch moves
okay 97
E5 should be coming soon
thank you Matthew pog
happy two years 24 months
also happy Pond Center
pawns are much happier now
um a man without the source is lost but
the same man can get lost in the source
you dig
sauce
might depend on the type of sauce
how to do this queenie7
27 walks into a pin
and just defending the knights can we
see a scotch Gambit
very possibly
I I did say at the beginning of the
stream I'll try and satisfy some
opening requests
okay
so I'm reasonably done with development
but there's definitely definitely a few
ways to improve
ooh
confrontational
yeah I think the goal is now to just
attack
with the pawn storm like Queen G6 G4
maybe throw in H5
get the Connect Four
wall of Hans
I just realized I'm one rating point
away from
getting back to 2600
yeah I'm trying to to play at a decent
level
at least with these first several games
okay this is looking really Pleasant
I'll get the other rook in so this over
defends e-pawn preparing
F4 but let's start with a knight
ooh so I could take this pawn two
different ways
I could also take the bishop
and taking the bishop actually looks
really attractive
declining on Busan
because I want to leave the pawn here
which just kills the life of this bishop
and now G4
some idea to play G3
have even more fun
I'll gladly accept the brick for
declining on poisson
there's more beautiful things to come
I could take it with Pawn
kind of allows that five
we'll take with Queen
ooh
okay now I'll just take a free Pawn
so up upon here have the bishop pair
this piece is just suffering
G3 is coming
I could take the Rook but
no about this my opponent found the one
way to prevent me from taking the Rook
I can't even drag to take it
okay GG
that was a pretty successful Dutch
I don't play The Dutch too often
but when I do
it's yeah it's it's fun opening content
having a little bit of allergies
yeah I might be allergic to
not taking on poisson
the next opportunity I can I probably
will
okay so what did people oh that's
berserk
people were asking for scotched Gambit
which I believe is this
and then Bishop C4
okay
who was asking for this
diadem
who subbed for three months
so Scotch Gambit can actually transpose
into different openings
um for example
now we have a napkinson
uh oh Knight C3 is actually
um
a fine move
and D5 is usually the main move here
okay this move I don't think is supposed
to be that great but why
you just Queen here
threatening Mage and the queen E7 I have
rookie one
of Queen here and then like rookie one
Bishop G5
it's very important my knight defends a
rook
oh no box Queen
and after it takes takes I'll still be
threatening F7
I wouldn't be surprised if
black resigns here but we might see
takes in Knight d8
I also wouldn't be surprised if this
exact position has happened a few times
before
in the lead chest database
that's kind of a natural line for Bach
to walk into
no mercy here
Happy 10 months
Happy 10 months
okay I'll take this first
I think you JD Rado
okay now I just want to bring the rest
of my pieces in
there's generally a few strategies
to employ when you're a material one is
to trade
to just simplify and win in the ending
but another strategy is to attack
is if if I have more pieces and I can
very likely overpower the opponent
oh
okay painting the knights
to The Rook which is pinned to the king
this would be a funny move exploiting
the fact that both pieces are pinned and
neither one would really want to take
oh fancy move so if I take with Queen I
don't even get mated because Bishop F1
I'll take with Pawn
maintaining the PIN
and it should be made in like at least a
move or two more or at most a move or
two more
yeah this is made into C6 and then Queen
E7 mate
okay
back to tournament
so yeah if you're just joining I don't
know how much of this I'll play at least
for this stream I think it's likely I'll
stream for a few hours and then
uh resume tomorrow for the finale
um but I don't want to burn myself out
like I have other plans this weekend
still trying to cross 2600
still trying to break into the top 2000
three games down
playing this person
it is cool that a lot of my opponents I
think all my opponents so far have never
played before
um
I'm still insistent on getting a staffer
insistent persistent staff Regatta time
I will mix up the openings later
but we need at least one zapper got it
there's a lot of moves white can play um
Bisbee 2 is most common
still a theory
oh you're welcome to day Adam who is the
one that requested the scotch cabinet
earlier
was trying to make you you proud and
satisfied
oh King H1 I don't think I've seen
before
I think the same idea applies
just running this
I'm actually now threatening this as
well
so F4 looks like it defends but then
Knight F2
which would win some material
oh white defended the F Pawn what do I
do with my life
one didn't even give me time to track
native
okay I keep gaining zero rating points
what to do
okay how many times has this exact game
happened before
let's see King H1 might be a new move
though
King H1 played 32 times Knight G4
Queen E1 has been played twice
but in only one of those games Queen H2
has played
okay
back to tournaments
a very successful Stafford
only four games in
top 2000 now
top 1700.
yeah a lot of people are asking if I'm
playing the whole thing
but the answer is
um I don't know how much I'll play
I'm gonna try and be reasonable I'm
gonna also listen to my body and my
energy levels and my brain
uh I'll berserk
and
someone earlier I saw in chat was asking
for Smith Mora
but here we have a nimsovich
which
I'll play D4 D4 is the most principled
move
and then like C3
kind of special preparation
D5
so ideas after 95 I play Queen D4
here Queen D4 is popped on to watch if
odd and got you live oh nice nice
welcome to pack Shipman
good timing happy 20 months
okay I should move for the quicker Pacer
scheme
um
debating what to do though
like I don't want to trade but I don't
want to lose a pawn either
so I think this is this is probably the
most reasonable move
it seems strange just to move back to
where I came from but it keeps upon
defended
okay
Bishop G5
eventually I want to play this move
yeah so take some then Bishop B5
and now black should be in trouble there
is C60
[Music]
that's not so simple
hmm
I'm not actually winning anything
I was about to blunder Queen A5 too
okay let's take and play Queenie two
it's a good position though
Queen E2 comes with Tempo Rook D1 can
come with tempo
that's a move have to play Bishop D2
considering castling Queen sign
I could take
uh I'm overthinking everything let's
play this move
defending activating leaving tension
I like the bishop here because it
kind of slows down Black's development
and blocks kingside development is
already kind of slow
from this opening
so we could trade Queens
okay I'll take
um
hitting the bishop
yeah if I take care of Rook G8
oh
okay
yeah that was just a free Pawn
and Lock's playing a good game overall
especially for the rating
but things are decently under control
[Music]
so Rook A1 and just King Z2
uh that's a fine move
doesn't quite work
I got to move a lot quicker
F6 may be coming
F5 is an idea
okay so I defend
I should have played Knight C4
okay oh that's not good
wow I'm in big trouble
I think I'm gonna lose this
never mind
now let's close
I think I'm winning now
it was really close
wow Queen D5 checkmate
okay
oh I don't have my heart rate monitor on
that was a big wake-up call
oh man
I mean I was in huge trouble
Bach played really well I was in
difficult position and
just kept holding on
eventually I blundered the fork
but then black under the fork pack
okay I'm sure my heart rate like this
stream has been averaging
well below 100
so okay finally back below 100 that's
good
back to tournaments hey I gained a
rating point I'm back over 2600 or back
at 2600 on the DOT
okay
have to stay calm
oh man this person
playing a lot of games
I played that was my fifth game right
okay I'll berserk again
come back [ __ ] oh thanks so much back
[ __ ] man
yeah that was um
that was a pretty miraculous comeback
but that's why you should never never
give up
always have hope
uh where's my win
I mean I could take and check
for H4
it was a very aggressive move but
I'm trying to
punish black slacker development
wow
play this move there's Queen D4
now I'm just confused maybe I'll play
this
attacking the Knight
if Knight E7 I'll have some fun with a
king
I don't think you need donate
and gifting to vanilla spoon
27
yeah that loses a piece
okay so now I'm up a rook
die blunder
I kind of blundered I should have taken
with Queen
this is another wake-up call
uh Bishop B6 was more possible there
I watched your videos to calm down
yesterday before NBA interviews oh nice
thanks for being the world's wholesome
chess creator
wait MBA
oh NBA
at first I heard NBA like uh basketball
and assumes that maybe you're a
professional basketball player
but NBA like um
like getting a MBA degree or masters of
Business Administration okay
well that's nice to hear
I'm happy I can help in some way
thank you Kodiak iron
so there is takes takes takes but then
I'm up
still up a rook
okay here I hold on to the bishop
so I'm up a rook and a knight here
yeah here it's just a matter of being
solid
um
I wouldn't mind the queen trade
I also don't mind if Queen stay on the
ball right now
Queen B5 is probably the best try
or that
okay so I want to win the pawn
oops
I'm missing so many things
I don't think I'm losing though
I just should not have allowed Queen F2
uh King C1 probably
wait a minute
how bad is this
it's a miracle my Bishop defends a night
no this is all fine
I'm just losing my Rook
oh no both my Rooks
okay
I really have to be more mental he's
involved with these games
I'm still undefeated though
it still feels like I'm kind of warming
up
thank you Dave W
let's go let's go I'm playing a reverse
Smith Mora
because no one's been playing Sicilian
today I have to
get some kind of Smith Mora
oh
okay so white soul and gamuting I mean
this is just a trade though
I get some Tempo on the queen
I think it's typical to play like some
idea Knight A6 might be four or Knight
A6 might be five
depending where the queen moves
yeah I'm gonna try and be aggressive
this game
like my goal is to actually try and win
out of the opening
it feels like there's going to be some
like potential traps and tactics
like Knight of three looks natural but
the knights C5 and then E4 can come
my T3 is a better move
now I'll play Bishop C5
oh okay
I want to punish this move I have Queen
D4
I think Bishop E7 is simple
restricting the Knight and then
preparing F5
yeah E4 is now coming very soon
and that can come in with tempo
so basically starting with that five
like most of my moves will come
with some kind of attack
and I'll also be moving forward White's
gonna have to start retreating
like Knight C3 and then after Knight C5
the queen will have to retreat
it's actually a funny line
I'm calculating a knight C3 Knight C5
Queen C2 E4 Knight E5
and then Queen D4 in the very end
which almost traps some Knights
oh yeah marathons usually
um vary when it comes to time control
it ranges from 5032 just for to 2000
rating and puzzles thank you so much for
all the helpful content only 1 300 on
rapid still do you have any tips to
translate puzzles into real games also
quack
this was a very simple puzzle
taking the free piece
um
I'm not sure if I understand the
question
also good job Obama official keep it up
um
I mean when you train puzzles it should
train kind of pattern recognition
so that
when you're in a real game you should be
quicker to spot certain tactical
patterns
like one very simple pattern is being
able to identify
undefended pieces
of of yourself but also of an opponent
and sometimes this will lead to tactics
this is probably the simplest tactic in
chess is take the free piece
um but there's other times where
um
yeah training a certain type of puzzle
will make it easier to spot the pattern
in real game
okay 888
gradually moving up
I have 28 tournament points
leader has 246. that's crazy
this is barely lost any games
leader has only lost two games
thank you JX
okay I'll play D4
I've not played D4 yet today
Bishop F5 okay
generally against a copycat
London I like to play C4
[Music]
um
kind of deviating from the usual C3
setup but the idea is to attack the B7
Pawn
like the main target
and yeah in some sense the queen side is
now a bit softer
like light squares are a bit weak
not the easiest to exploit though
I mean the plan was probably Knight E5
Rook C1
he's starting with Rick C1
and eventually takes and then use the
light squared Bishop
thank you hydromaniac
yeah there's actually a ton of tactical
potential here I should have probably
considered Knight B5
um
I'm pretty sure I'm winning The Rook
s here Bishop E7
The Rook is almost trapped
there was Rook C4 in Knight T2 but
um
yeah I guess I'll take the Rook
that was a nice opening
and it only gets nicer
did I miss Knight D5
I mean
oh no I might Rook was undefended
earlier
okay so I have a queen of her Bishop
life is pretty good
I'll take the Rope next move
okay no mercy
I really haven't won too many games in
my meeting
like most opponents resigned before made
happens
pretty sure
that was Unstoppable
okay
it's still a 2600. I've only gained two
points this tournament so far
but we'll keep it up
oh the strongest player I've played so
far
okay no berserking I'll play an English
opening
I'll keep mixing up the openings
yeah English can very often transpose
into other openings so we're actually
transposing into a Sicilian
it's like a Marathi bind against
Hedgehog
which is an opening I've I've played
many times and tournaments over the
years
Vienna at some point
sure I'll keep that in mind
yeah I think this is all very standard
in Bishop F1 Queen F2 and some eventual
G4
G4 defends H Pawn
kind of anticipating the smooth
I've also played like similar lines as
black so
again
I kind of played this position from both
colors
uh but it's been a while since I've had
this sort of setup
H4 is a move
hey it's Andres what's up Andres
appreciate the rain
I'm debating what to do here
actually considering 92 Knight G3
which also unleashes a rook so I'm
trying to discourage uh D5
and D5 also can sometimes be met with G5
thank you Mr barf man appreciate the
prime sub
I am usually friendly with animals
at least most animals but this this
animal
[Music]
I mean it's it's trying to hurt me with
all the the pointy spikes
so I have to try and hurt it back
usually I like to use animals to hurt my
opponents
I used to have a whole series on YouTube
there is a video like don't mess with my
walrus don't mess with my hippo
don't mess with my hedgehog
I have played this opening is back
yeah more recently it's been don't mess
with my duck
actually I took a walk in the park today
and I saw a couple
real life ducks
I took some photos
I did put a funny photo on my Instagram
story
would you rather have pet elephant or
pet hippo
aren't hippo is like really dangerous
while elephants are like kind of
friendly and intelligent
so probably an elephant
but if I had a pet elephant right now I
would probably have to address
the elephant in the room
but thankfully I don't
want to play this move
idea F4 and Bishop G2
had to over defend G4
oh yeah an elephant is also a type of
chess piece
oh which reminds me
I received a gift earlier
I saw Yasser earlier and he gave me uh
these custom sarawan chess pieces
one of which was an elephant
but it's in a different room so
I can't address elephant in this room
foreign
yeah a few days ago I had given Yasser a
duck
so this was his uh return gift
to give me the elephant in the hawk
yeah it's getting spicy wow it's getting
really spicy
so I win a piece I lose some Pawns
as long as f4c is defended it takes
takes I still have two Defenders
I mean we might see D4 actually
but I can dig with rook and then Queen
up over two minutes on the clock
best sub of all time hey happy 22 months
yeah I appreciate all the subs apologies
if I didn't like address everyone but I
do appreciate the support
when would you play blindfold symbols
again ooh
maybe in the near future hopefully
before the end of this month
I do have my blindfold it's been
patiently sitting on my desk
haven't used it in uh
in recent times
okay so takes takes Rook C2 in the end
foreign
G3 Rook G2 and then
I'm the one attacking on the G file
I'm also controlling D file which is
nice
and black only has two pawns for the
piece
this move
can we have to choose a safer option
Knight D5 is a crazy option I don't
think it works though
I'll play this
I'm just being safe
yeah I have the D5 Square now for the
knights
don't prep at me
okay
okay that was a nice finish
that was the highest rated opponent I
played so far
uh
um
yeah I'm pretty sure like this position
is probably some Theory
and quick analysis
in the 22 games in Master's database
before it played six times before
what will engines say
oh engine says like a nice Plus for
white
I consider G5 but after Knight H5
I guess the engine just likes white
space advantage
ah there's this idea
Bishop H3 is nice
okay
I think overall I think that was a nice
game
like pretty clean too made three
inaccuracies
okay back to tournaments
37 tournament points
yeah in a future stream I'll I'll do
some Show and Tell with uh Sarah on
pieces
they're just far away from me right now
and uh the goal is to
just grind out more chests
feel free to suggest openings
um I already played Stafford that worked
well
I'll play an alkyne
this could kind of transpose the scandi
yeah this is some line of this candy
um I think Bishop C4 is a little bit
more common
oh this reminds me of duck chess in Duck
chess I play Knight F4 and duck F1
I don't think Knight of four is so good
in this position though
just continue developing
uh maybe bishop D6
she is
cheers happy 19 months to thino
reinforcing the knights
okay now Knight F4 makes some more sense
I think I'll play another four
it's essentially an attempt to get the
bishop here
thank you for all your inspiring content
someday I hope to meet you in person oh
my pleasure
welcome back to Mark shark
okay one of the ultra aggressive here
I think it's okay actually each five
oh no my Bishop
yeah one goal with this opening actually
is to
castle queenside and then go crazy on
the key on the king side
like maybe later G5 F5
Etc
I played G5 now
it looks fun
let's do it
this might be slightly irresponsible but
it's one way to have a good time
yeah I don't know when I'll do a like a
meet and greet
maybe in Toronto actually going to
Toronto
the first week of November
I'm sure there will be opportunities to
meet fans there this is a good move by
the way
I have to be careful this is coming
maybe Queen E7
kind of giving up on this battery but
I'm ensuring the night's restricted
F5 might be coming next
wow
should I self-trap my own Bishop
oh it's such a weird configuration
maybe uh maybe E5 is coming next
it's like Connect Four
supporting the two Bishops
maybe C5 will come too to kick the
Knight away
oh okay any tea recommendations for The
Fall season
yes I do I'm in the process of hopefully
forming a
a tea partnership
um oh
[Music]
oh no my queen
someone call an ambulance
but not for me
okay thanks for the game
to my opponents
um
yeah there's been a a company I recently
discovered through a friend that's
called uproots tea
and they're based in I believe they're
based in Colorado but they ship
I think they ship like nationally or
internationally or both
and they have like super good quality
um
I recently had the this Japanese Sentra
tea which was amazing
and hopefully like in the very near
future I'll I'll have some more
established partnership
okay back to tournament
welcome back to turbochuk
some nice game so far
maybe only a couple games where I've
been in trouble but
I've been uh
I've been avoiding losing so that's a
good sign
Tennyson did you celebrate with fobby
don't think it's a coincident he played
the Stafford you recommended then became
U.S champion in a matter of weeks he
definitely not a coincidence
uh yeah yeah I saw I mean I was at the
closing ceremony yesterday and
[Music]
um
yeah it was amazing to see Fabi win
the whole tournament
okay I'm berserking
against uh decently high rated player
thanks for the quack so I'm allowing
this okay this is a funny line takes and
then takes
and then
opponent may be considering this but
that's less fun
assuming takes takes others there's four
Queens on the board by move seven
no I'm sad now
what to do
opponent didn't go into my funny line
and this is probably a better way to
play for black
I'm still sad
I also might be losing a pong
maybe I should have played C3
okay now B7
I think it's okay Rook bi can take in
Bishop C6
I mean the resulting position is kind of
Josh
like assuming we trade Queens it's
some obstacle or Bishop ending
but it'll be an end green grind
I'm trying to make up for
a loss of time
also I should explain what berserking is
because there's always people watching
like on in twitch and on YouTube who
are wondering why I started the game
with less time
um it's kind of a unique thing that you
can do in Lee chess Arena tournaments
where you you give time odds essentially
but if you win the game you get one
extra points for the tournament
standings
so it's a way to try and accelerate your
um
your progress in the tournament
it usually makes sense to do against
much lowering players
foreign
yeah this could be a long fight
realizing I should probably play Rook B3
Bishop here first
preventing this move
yeah Optical our Bishop situations can
be very deceiving too because sometimes
they look very drawn and sometimes they
are just objectively drawn
but
it can also lead to situations where
like both sides can play for a win
I'm going for more trades here
yeah especially if there's Rooks on the
board
I'm leaving tension because it would be
nice to fix the structure
like we both have these separated pong
Islands
A4 me becoming so maybe I can play A4
myself
idea Bishop B5
also the idea of blundering upon
not my proudest idea but I might be
winning it back
that's kind of interesting still
my past G Pawn
um this is gonna take a ton of work
though
I'm playing verwin now
but I'll think about the draw offer just
give me another minute to think about it
okay
oh
Punk could have sacked
okay I'm turning this now
opponent can do the same thing to me
it's like parallel universes
[Music]
foreign
foreign
oh wow it's 50 move rule
I forgot about the 50 move rule
oh good game
it was a very tricky position actually
because
there's points where I can try and
consider playing G5
um that's actually crazy that we played
50 moves there
wow
oh no my heart rate good game
okay that's my first reading loss of the
tournament first draw of the tournament
so out of all the games I played
what how many wins
10 wins in one draw
I've lost one rating point
oh what to do
okay
um maybe I shouldn't berserk
but maybe I should
okay I'm just working let's play um play
my usual stuff
Queen's got declined
I'm gonna try and go for Cambridge
Springs
yeah Cambridge Springs time
the opening that can be very effective
at like Club level
especially against opponents like below
below 2000 below 2200
it's also uncommon enough where a lot of
players just don't know what to do
against it
so this is one of the main lines
nice thing about taking with Knight is I
keep the rink open
to attack the bishop
I'm also putting on more pressure
against C3
I'm castling here
I think white might be following some
Theory here
I don't think this is a theory
so we're going to see a very common
theme in this whole
where this bishop is currently hanging
if I take it right away I lose this
bishop so
I can take this Pawn First
and then take the bishop
so I'm up a pawn but it still takes work
because my Bishop is kind of sad
it's one of the downsides of this
opening
at some point I want to play this and
this and like Bishop B7
it might involve sacking upon
like there's also an idea five ideas
how to do this
I mean 95 first
okay trying to optimize the Rooks
E4 is probably coming
and G6 is nice so it restricts the
bishop
it gives my queen room to move and then
hopefully I can gradually untangle
okay now B5
this is the first step getting the
bishop said the long diagonal the next
step is actually opening the diagonal
um this move is enticing
I think I'll play it
I mean I'm allowing some crazy socks
like takes takes takes
but I'm also threatening this and this
good move
calculating negative three and then C5
which I think is okay
I know 3c5
takes and then takes
and what used to be my worst piece could
very soon become the best piece
yeah don't mess with my wooden Shield
now D3 is under my control too
so there's ideas of
I mean Knight D3 or Bishop D3 do I fork
or do I trap I just have to move
midnight D3 will come later
I'm hitting the rook and Pawn
the dream is to play Queen D4
and then somehow smother mate but that's
still very far away
okay this Rook is almost trapped
although I guess yeah the queen supports
it
is trying to find the meeting idea like
after Queen F1
foreign
Ty too
overpowering
plenty of time
it's going to take a while to make it
back to 2600
because I I think this game will give me
zero rating points
but this is a nice game overall nice
kind of demonstration of the
Venom of the Cambridge Springs
the other day I shared a Google form of
um
basically requesting feedback
about potentially making a chess course
and I got a ton of feedback and there is
it seemed like there is high demand for
a course
on what to do as black against D4
so I'm highly considering making a
course of like a Cambridge Springs
repertoire that also covers like
anti-lungen and anti-stone wall and
jobava London so we do have the form
command
also thanks so much thirsty monster
appreciate the rain
shout out to Thirsty monster
if you're just joining
it's uh
Autumn Marathon
2022.
I actually didn't know this tournament
was taking place until like earlier
today
um buy joins about four hours late
uh which was about 80 minutes ago
I'm finally in the top 500
let's go
at the very least I'm going to try and
make it to top 100 and then
I'll see how tired I am
okay I'll play the same repertoire
oh
I was just speaking of anti-jobava
London
I don't think there's a need for uh
predictions the Stream
because there's just so many unknowns of
like how long I'm gonna play
I might take some breaks at some points
but I'll make an effort to look at chat
like between games for opening requests
so I know we were getting some earlier
and I've already fulfilled a few I think
between Dutch and uh Scotch gamut
long time viewer first time chatter but
loved the content for years now smile
thanks oh thanks so much
rules of Glory
appreciate that
um
yeah this is already a nice position
white plate looks kind of a strange
opening it seemed like it was going to
be Joe Bava London but now the pawn is
black and the bishop
um
that's still a question how to
improve
E4 makes sense
actually E4 makes a ton of sense
especially now that the bishop can't
return to E2
the F3 square is going to be really weak
now it's just a matter of getting a
knight there
the B5 Bishop b395
G5 Knight F3 King F1
so maybe Queen G6 first
and preparing queen's eye Gosling
okay now some B4 idea
still trying to make sense of this
seems like it should be good
so I'm allowing G5
opponent doesn't go for
okay now I'm discouraging G5 but it's
still a playable move
interesting
so there's three attackers
um
I think I have to play Knight C4
this is the only way I saw to the defend
D5
and the d-pawn is pinned to the queen
but this doesn't work because
I take take take and then win material
okay so now G5
things are getting spicy
I really want to take on E3
I don't think that works
I think I'll take in greenside Castle
and queen size is very airy I've moved
all my pawns on the queen side
but uh okay now I have another Defender
on D5 it looks really risky for white to
take the pawn
like there's a funny line uh Queen G7
Rook GA queen of seven broke H7 I think
would trap the queen
now I think that line is still possible
here here here and then there
I guess there's Rook D5 in that line
but then I take the queen
the pawns are smiling
represent A7
the last Bishop C3
oh I still have the same idea
okay so I'm basically trying to provoke
white to take the pawn
and white did
okay so Knights defended
this is the whole idea look at this
chain of Defense
the bishop defends the queen defends the
Knight defends both Rooks Rook on each
side attacks the White Queen and all the
squares are taken away
so I control the seventh rank with x-ray
vision this Rook controls the G file
uh uh I control H5
these scores are controlled back ranks
controlled
this queen is uh
kind of stuck
and if Rook D5
I just take the queen
so it's important that my um my Bishop
defends my queen
okay let's move back
so now I have Queen for Rook
it's still all over though
a little bit awkward here
it's actually a good move
let's defend
so Bishop C3 probably there's a B4
yeah there's weird tactics
considering D4 here
which doesn't do that much
so maybe this move
yeah white definitely has some
compensation
okay now D4
looks nice
I'm getting out of the PIN
E3 is a threats
and G4 is hanging
I think overall nice game
foreign
thank you hijinx welcome back
happy 26 months
I'm trying to make progress
uh
and White's kind of solid on the back
couple rings
but simple thread of this
ah but then Bishop D6
so maybe this
threading this
I got no mercy now
thank you Jay Smith Festival
also thank you fine I will join twitch
nice username oh no my queen
oh yes my queen
okay
does that count for an oh no my queen
rosendrophy
it depends on the like the algorithm
right
let's see
xlam Rosen score
let's go in here
how many rows and trophies have I had
I've gotten one Rosen trophy
against this person
oh so that previous game didn't count as
a Rosen trophy
but this one did okay
yeah this was a game from earlier
where I didn't promote
that's interesting
because I guess this was basically oh no
my pong like the pawn was very
temporarily a queen
okay back to tournaments
okay
all berserk too
oh someone was asking for Tennyson
earlier
well now we have
uh what do we have
let's play B3
I'm like Carlos sometimes likes to play
this
foreign
type structure
which looks reasonable
not sure what my Bishop is doing on D6
it's just kind of chilling though
trying to be cool also trying to win
material
uh yeah let's go for the attack
like Rook lifting time
maybe some light lifting
I'm actually threatening to trap The
Black Queen here which is kind of cool
because the Queen the usual safe squares
for the queen are no longer safe because
the jifong would be pinned
so we have yet another queen drop
okay
take with Queen
yeah I'm intentionally losing the pawn
because after I take on D3 I'd be
hitting
a few things
okay now just attacking the Knight
and nothing else
uh opponent didn't see me wink
GG
so I've had one draw
out of 14 games
my rating has just stayed the same
I started this term in the 20
5.98
oh yeah regarding the elephant in the
room we had this discussion earlier
but the elephant is in the other room
so maybe at some point I'll go and get
it to show
it was a very uh
it was a very nice gift from Yasser
so I'm excited to play some more sarawan
chess OTB
okay I know someone wanted hillbilly
there was some chat from earlier I
remember seeing decided to join the
tourney won my first three games hey
let's go keep it up
real head turner
you made me turn my head
uh I'll play this
and going for E5
I'm allowing D4 but then Knight T1
and then I can gradually
wow a 15 months already wow
welcome back to cinema
happy 15.
so this resembles kind of a Grand Prix
attack
very similar setup
yeah play an elephant Gambit it's my fav
black opening
um
I I'll consider playing this
I remember getting a lesson in the
elephant
from uh minlay he was like one of the
world's leading specialists in an
opening
okay
not gonna waste any time with attack
a pawn Storm is Coming
the Knight is now trapped
and the attack won't stop oh yes my sub
oh yes thanks to all the subs
thank you Crow missed first time Prime
paparino
14 months with Prime
man that's uh that requires dedication I
do appreciate those who like manually
check to see if they can resub with
prime every month
it does help support the channel
it also helps keep me awake in these uh
long Marathon streams
yeah G5 G6 is uh on its way
maybe E5 for good measure oops
E5 not possible
so it's Lisa uh upon is pinned no F6
H6 was coming very soon
foreign
I'm happy to open each file
uh this Rook is attacked do I want to
take it I probably do
oh no my queen
I I've had a few very short-lived Queens
this uh this tournament
this queen is living a longer life
but it might be coming to an end
oh that's unfortunate okay let's play
this move
if Knight G8
and I'm talking from all directions
oh no my queen
okay a nice finish
no mercy that game
thank you waffles reborn that's a nice
username
first time Prime
hey welcome back to Sam
yeah so if you're just joining
I've played 15 games so far
I'm undefeated
but I'm not undrawn I had one draw
uh
but I'll try and keep my undefeated
streak
um I think I saw emberg earlier asking
for a bush gas Gambit which is very
similar to Stafford Gambit
but I guess it's also a little bit
different
this is here I'm allowing 95
and here
I might as well go crazy I'll play a
reverse Evans Gambit how about
the ubsds another first time Prime
reverse Evans Gambit declined
so now my Pawn is just sitting on B5
well there's some logic to it
I win this Pawn
this Pawn kind of looks poisonous
but it also looks tasty
like a wild mushroom let's eat it
and see what happens
there's sometimes things you can do in
chess that you probably shouldn't do in
real life
wow
wow
what's going on here
this is a threat of a triple attack so
G6 I get Triple attacked the thing is
the Knight is hanging in some lines
um so I think I'll play King f8
this would be a double attack
and then I probably play this
okay that makes me more comfortable
I could play Queen E8
I'll start with an F6
so I basically won a bishop
Rooks attacked
Queen E7
or queen E8
and supports C6
I hate to say this but I'm already
feeling kind of tired
if I'll just try and Bower through
still very early in the Stream
maybe I'll have to play more exciting
openings to keep waking myself up
okay
um I take
no need to take
considering this move
or this move
I'll just trade
I'm gonna hold off on drinking coffee
I think my plan is to just stop
streaming when I got really tired
and then
try and get some sleep I'll try and get
like a good eight hours
and then probably have some coffee in
the morning
and I think it's very likely all like
stream several hours tomorrow like
through the
of the tournaments
and I'll see how high I can finish
I'm in Central Time so it's it's 12 35
a.m for me oh no my Pawn
yeah The Bishop's gonna find a happy
place
a rookie two
the other other pieces will also find
Happy places
Rook B7 first
and clever
I'm calculating some funny line like
takes and then takes and then here and
then here and then oh no my Pawn
and then on the White's King
oh no my Pawn
I think my opponent's good enough to
spather The Rook has to stay
on the back rink
I push
okay C1 Queen is coming
yeah there's no need to like rush to
Queen okay now
there is no reason not to Queen there
I'm still looking for the most efficient
mate
I think it involves Queen G3 except not
in this position
okay
okay
um moving on
so that was uh the bush gas turned into
a reverse delayed Evans gambits
top 300.
a liter has almost 300 tournament points
I still have a lot of catching up to do
I'll bizarre kind of risky
but uh I might as well
I'll play a Sicilian
I haven't played a single Cecilia in
this tournament I don't think
I'll play taimanov
I think D5
I think in general this is a very simple
solid variation for Bach
I have two Center pawns against zero
Center Pawns
and ready to Castle
I think in the middle game I just want
to use the files
okay I can't play Rook B8
but something like Rook C8
this Rook C8
and C4 looks like a nice Square for The
Rook
and then some double up
imagine Wade will like look to
I was thinking like Queen F3 Rook ad1
but
Rook B1 may be going for some
I don't know the pawn should probably
stay on B2 defending the knights
now there's already some Prospect of D4
because Knight's kind of pinned to the C
Pawn
like D4 right now
D4 there is takes takes 94.
not sure about
maybe A5
no rush
I think some idea a483
I'm trying to destabilize this whole
setup
and the way to do that is to get the
pawn to A3
oh
okay bring the queen in
now this move not only does it add more
pressure to the C file but also enables
this
which looks nice hitting the bishop
if I can
provoke the bishop to move away and then
Bishop F6 is uh coming soon
or it takes and then Bishop F6
I mean so far it's just been a matter of
like continually improving the pieces
all working towards a common goal
Apon included
now I have four attackers against Knight
only two Defenders
I guess 92
then I take
I actually actually can choose which
Pawn to take lights pins of both Pawns
I'm also realizing I'm threatening D4
which maybe it probably wasn't good last
move
but it's definitely a threat if
okay white deals with it
okay Colin a second Pawn
and the time situation is not bad at all
um
that's a nice thing about 5-0 like a 5-0
Arena when you berserk you still get two
and a half minutes
which is a lot of time
like I'm used to playing 3-0 so two and
a half minutes is not much
less than 3-0
okay now I go for trades
I might as well
yeah white doesn't want to trade too
much
okay making Luft
no rush
maybe Queen C4 coming
um
foreign
Rook C1
doesn't quite work because Rook D1
[Music]
maybe now Queen F1
preparing this
guy I don't think why it's stopping meat
there's one there's a couple checks
but because my knight also covers G3
there's no
Escape for the king
welcome to Temp G
first time chat singer watched on YT
big fan
good to have you here yeah welcome to
all the people who usually watch on
YouTube
may be watching for the first time on
Twitch
I mean this will probably go on YouTube
in the future so shout out to all the
people watching in the future on YouTube
which is probably the present time for
you
leave a comment if you made it this far
uh that was a nice game nice kind of
instructive Sicilian
how to transform like a small positional
Advantage the fact that I was
controlling a bit more space I had the
files to work with
and the pawns were targets and
I was just kind of constant positional
pressure
okay back to tournaments
hey I'm back to 25.99
uh trying to gain one more points
okay playing fractal gaming
I was working
okay I'm willingly going into a French
I think I saw the mention of French
earlier in chat so maybe if I have a
chance I'll play French as black as well
wow G6
it's a weird idea for French because
usually the bishop develops here here
this is some kind of strange sideline
foreign
if I watch the Youtube video too am I
watching the past from the future or am
I now watching a future video from the
past
uh that's a great question which I don't
have the mental capacity to try and
answer right now
but I appreciate your curiosity
I also appreciate my squeeze on the
position
[Music]
and Glock is kind of paralyzed
I wanted to play B4 but then Queen E3
[Music]
but the I mean The Rook is blocked by
the bishop which is blocked by the
Knight which has no moves
which is blocked by this bishop
which is blocked by the pawn so maybe a
lot can untangle somehow
okay this is kind of cruel
to just go after the H Pawn
but I might as well
oh this is double attack wow
uh
debating
I think this is okay uh
probably should not have allowed that
let's take on each seven
the prospect of pushing my pondage seven
looks really nice
and I don't think black is doing much
damage like even if Knight T4 I just
kind of ignore it
also thank you pardon the pun appreciate
the five gifted
foreign
just show no mercy to the French
but I think if I'm black next game I'll
I'll play E6 first move regardless
and we'll see what happens
yeah this is just a deadly threat
Bishop H6 was expected
now it's a matter of just winning
with the material advantage and not
flagging
uh can I take on these seven
no need
yeah there's still a nice grip in the on
the position
[Music]
uh complete development
some idea to take and then take
hmm
now we're doing some weird dance
not quite a Tick-Tock worthy dance
foreign
only two Defenders this move's probably
coming
if this move comes we'll see a really
beautiful pork
I'm also kind of low on time
okay look at this pork
not the most kosher pork but
oh that was very tasty
and now
it should be made very soon E6
plenty of time
I'm gonna try and get upon me actually
King Yi and then Pawn takes
this is double checkmate with a pond
okay
that was nice
my reading stays the same
okay next game let me try and show
how the French should be played
oh I'm white okay
uh I won't berserk I'll play E4
I'll play my usual Knight C3 Sicilian
okay going for one of the more direct
lines
Knight C6
I think Bishop D2 is a fair approach
discouraging Queen A5
hmm
wow
yeah that's gonna have to probably
Gambit like B6
so I don't think black's winning back by
Pawn
but maybe I'll be proven wrong and queen
hits the pawn
all defend
this actually looks really nice now
the pawn controls a lot of space D6
could run into takes in Knight B5
and I also have easy development
92 in castling
um yeah D6 might be coming
like Knight D5 is interesting
I'm also just trying to figure out like
Knight B5 Queen C6 Knight D4 I lose a
pawn and a five
I take only seven
no need to overthink things like D6 I
probably just taken Queen C1
yeah maybe there is something better but
uh
I think this still looks nice there's
actually a double thread Knight B5 but
also Pawn F4 and then Pawn E5
black probably has to move the Rook
The Rook is being targeted by both
tactics
the bishop G7 F4
I'm realizing it's not so simple
F4 Knight G4 E5 takes takes takes King
F2
I'm gonna go for it
I think it might just win a rook
yeah there's a line Knight G4 E5 takes
and if I take with Queen there's Knights
G4 again
that might be the line I go for
okay here I can take
uh F7 is vulnerable
I'll play this first
thank you Carl
happy 19 months
yeah there's still Prospect of Knight D5
yeah I just want a castle soon too
I didn't wanna
give away each two
foreign
actually
if Knight takes I take with bishop and
hit the rook and F7
am I opponent only saw seven
so I'm up too much material hey okay I
passed 2600 yet again
let's go
staying undefeated
76 tournament points
performance rating is only 23.46 yes 2
600.
oh yes
thank you Mayo sanjar
I'll be there
okay I'm trying to play a French
we're not quite getting good friends so
I'll play e6b6
maybe I'll play like a delayed Dutch hey
it's Josh what's up Josh
appreciate the raid
if you're just joining it's a Autumn
Marathon
I am
just over two hours in
uh do I wanna
It's actually an interesting decision
I want to play this my business in this
place so I'll play this
exclamation mark anagram in rosenda
ooh is there a funny anagram to that
probably
wow
okay this is a funny line so there's
blonde Diamond potential
hi hi hi hi hi
I feel so greeted now I also feel kind
of low on time
uh 96 is coming
in Queen E7
Queen E7 is basically anticipating that
this move is going to happen
and then I move to E5 or C5 and defend
maybe C5
and after it takes takes I'll be one oh
does this move
like there's some idea to create
quadruple upon potential
still far away from it though
yeah this is useful because I not only
defense E7 but I also cover
E6
wow
is that a move
it's a move
not sure how great it is
takes takes takes I think I'll take with
Rook actually
so I prevent Queen H5 and now now I
allow Queen H5 I have G6
I think this is a simpler line
and now like King G8
because if here there's takes with Chuck
I also have King D7
King D7
ensuring The Rook has more
freedom
another watch my time
so I have four minor pieces still
B
thank you GM Mickey
not so focused on the B file I'm more
focused on the G file
also focus on White's threat
okay let's bring the Knight back to the
center
and there's some still attacking
potential
18 hours to go good luck
oh thank you
I just want to make a pawn diamond
uh let's start with this
I'll be patient
uh okay upon Diamond accomplished I got
my rules and trophy
wait I gotta move much much faster
can I get a second Frozen trophy Connect
Four
is that a frozen trophy I don't know
play this and then B4
Tetris piece incoming
oh look at these Pawns
they're so Majestic
and C3 is a big threat
I didn't really want to simplify it but
I have 14 seconds left
so now I have a night for a pawn
but these pawns are super super strong
so here I play this if here I play this
and that
oh no my Bishop
D3 coming next
it's still not simple
hello Eric him Rose and ducky
it was really not simple
to Pond or not to pond
oh no
foreign
plenty of time
usually 1.5 seconds isn't much time
but here it's plenty of time
oh it wasn't easy
heart rate getting up there okay
queen bb8 checkmates that might be the
first time in my life playing such such
a move
okay
uh uh yeah I got a little bit carried
away with the
the funny Pawn structure
let it paid off
let's go
yeah how many moves do I make in less
than two seconds I'm sure someone can
tell me
uh
if you quickly look at the the replay of
the game
uh no berserking I want to calm down
I'm gonna play Josh's favorite opening
not sure if Josh is still here but this
is called the Brooklyn defense
it's a slightly strange opening but uh
the point is I've made white overextend
hey Josh is still here
I played D5 now
if D5 we transpose into some
like Karo Khan
uh which is not a bad idea actually
okay Bishop D3 I think was far better
yeah this is basically like hero
calendar
or like a reverse
Queen's Gambit exchange variation
Queen C7
I think it's likely I'll end up Queen
psychosloin
try and make the game a bit sharper
foreign
[Music]
okay so I'm hitting this Pawn
wow it's after 1am so 105 am
I can't remember last time I streamed
after 1am
fancy move
now I'll take
I mean I kind of have to make a rule
that if I
If I Stay undefeated I can't end the
Stream
so in the
offhand chance that I just stay
undefeated for the rest of the stream
this could be like a 21 hour stream I
don't think that's the case though
but I just realized that
um what to do here I can take a pawn
could move the night
I don't really want to trade Queens
though
and D5 was a great move
yeah I really thought it was better but
it's not so simple
you know this move
just trying to fix my structure
I'm down about a minute
so I'm hitting the Knight and the pawn
both are undefended
yeah this is kind of a critical moment
for lights
because white could take like keep
Queens on the board maybe Queen d2's a
move
okay Queens are off the board
it's a fine move
so I'm calculating uh kind of a funny
line
which I think I'll go for
it's basically after it takes takes
takes I have Rook D2 Rogue F2 E4
which I'm realizing might not work
because I forgot about G4
but I'm going for it anyway
I also forgot about that move
oh no okay I have this move at least
and then G4 I take takes and then takes
but that's not so impressive for me
I think I have to start with this
and Bishop G6
and if I take take there's Rook F7
I don't see myself winning that
I mean if I keep the minor pieces on the
board at least I have some chances
like takes yeah I lose a pawn
and then
I mean I'm attacking this Pawn
okay white Caesar trap
uh I'm not actually losing this Pawn
at least yet
that's a good move
it takes upon there's work at fate
I think I take I just take care
what's the worst that happens
like even if white gets both Rooks to
like C7 B7 my king just stays here and
The Rook will defend the pawn
okay let's see where the white king goes
really
okay now there's winning chances
I hope
A5 no A6 let's just play this first
preventing Rook C6
oops
in this move
I hope I didn't batch this
it's very important I defend
also very important I can attack
okay now it's a matter of working up the
pawn
assuming I can get my Rook behind the
pawn
this should be winning
tricky let's cut off the king
a very important endgame concept coming
off the king
and now this that's still tricky
[Music]
I
think
just
this first
maybe this first
okay so I'm ensuring there's no Rook A6
okay now I'm ensuring there's Rook A6
for me
I think I found the ideal square of my
Rook
defending and supporting
okay A2 coming
oh very fancy
if I push there was some funny perpetual
which would have been not so funny for
me
are you two's still coming
just enough time
foreign
did I miss something
it's very possible I missed something
earlier
there is a comment
Miss Rook F3
I'll think about taking the draw in
in maybe just over a minute from now
wow opponent Rage Quit
oh no my opponent
what to do
well I can claim victory what's gonna
happen if there's still a draw for
wow there's so many buns to click
dull clean victory
there is a decline draw button there's
except draw button
there is a clean Victory button there's
also call draw button right there like
there were two draw buttons
there's also the resign button which
thankfully I didn't slip click
okay real quick
um not sure what moment Rook F3 could
have been played
I'm not sure Rogue three here loses our
Rook
I like my position and then like D5
happened
not sure if I've had better
but okay I gained a rating points
let's go
my heart is still beating that's also
nice
almost top hundred
without losing a game
I'll deserved
I really haven't played too many londons
yet
or any londons
okay we're playing this slime which is
not the most traditional London
this is one of these move orders where
black allows
the early Queen G4
and it's already a little bit unpleasant
for black
like G6 is some concession
dark Spurs are a bit weak around the
king side
[Music]
it should be pretty easy play
E4 is one of the main ideas
maybe F3 maybe this move to
actually like this move
because the problem is if the Knight
moves so the queen defends the pawn then
the queen is overworked because the
Knight wouldn't be defended by the other
night
so how does black defend the pawn the C6
runs into the fork
King d8 is super ugly but might be
necessary
king da like Queen G3 Knight B6
and queen F4
just a little bit more active
actually Queen F4 is more useful because
I keep an eye on the knights
and there's still the idea of um yeah
taking and then
oh I blundered no did I blunder
I blundered oops
yeah
that's not good
I just plundered
oh to do
I got too excited
I want to play Queen E5 if that doesn't
work at all
if I take
maybe I can get away with taking
actually
oh no my queen
because at least I win
what rook and Knight for queen
Rook Knight and Ponder Queen
so not even like technically down
material
I mean it wasn't necessary I probably
shouldn't have gone for this
but
we'll try and make it work
box pieces aren't too too impressive and
black does have the queen which
is usually a pretty impressive piece on
its own
it is nice that most of the pawns are on
light squares
so I have the better Bishop
potential for the knights
I'm thinking like C3 King B1 A3
could be a nice setup
yeah B5 I probably like King B1
there's actually a very solid position
oh I want to play B3
I could play C3 and say oh no my Rook
someone call an ambulance
except don't call an ambulance
the out of takes there was a fork
I was trying to deflect the bishop
uh oh let's go back
okay so now there's a simple plan of
doubling up
targeting the pawn there's also a plan
of uh G4 G5
hey it's Hannah
thank you Hannah appreciate the rain
if you're just joining
I'm very much missing my queen I
blundered earlier and I don't have a
queen but I have some material for the
queen
so I'm trying to make it work
always play King B1
also I berserk this game so I barely
have any time
I should have considered this move
okay this is one attempt to make
progress
not sure how effective this is though
because of G6 coming
okay the Knight wants to be here
and do some dancing
the bishop B5 rookie three
oh
okay
have some funny blockade now
yeah I think everything is under control
actually
like the queen can try and come in with
Bishop D1
like all the scores are pretty much
covered
this should be relatively easy to play
you can see one
I could have maybe taken the pawn
probably should have considered taking
the pawn
there we go
unnecessary but making progress
oh
a lot of D4
I think some funny mates
okay that was a close game
oh okay I gained our reading point for
that game I I berserk so I'm berserked I
got my queen dropped everything worked
out though
yeah shout out to Hannah
hope you had a good stream
for everyone just joining this is the
2022
all the marathon
I started two and a half hours ago
and I'm still undefeated and I'm top
hundred
let's go
it's London time
okay we'll go into the sign
oh this is actually a very
confrontational variation
I think 83 is the best move
this gets weird though
have to try and remember my prep
so the idea is to play Bishop C4 and
then Rook A2 and drop the queen
a lot of Queens have been trapped uh in
this tournament in my games
um
I mean I can play this too
let's start with this
so this is a threat and this is a threat
yeah Bishop C4 also threatens Rook B1
like both moves would drop the queen
I know there's a line where black like
intentionally sacks for rook and minor
piece
it might still be possible
although I guess
okay well now I can go through with
either plan
I think this is better
because Knight C7 Kings Y8 I wouldn't
want to walk into
Queen C3 check
so now
how to do this
whoa It's A1A just stopped by to give
you money
thanks for stopping by
oh you caught me at a tricky moment
because I'm trying to figure out
some life decisions
okay I'll drop the queen
I really appreciate the fifty dollars
it's very kind
I also appreciate winning a queen
and the fact that black didn't take on
E3
so many things to be grateful for
okay now it's just a matter of moving
quickly
I'm not getting too low on time
I think I'll go for
okay it's planning to take
um
okay no need to think
just have to play like Alpha zero
foreign
that was a
really bad move
where where was Ben Feingold to tell me
never play F3
how bad is this
okay visit here I drop the bishop
uh
uh I'm actually in like big trouble here
let's take
black has more than enough material for
the queen now
time wise it's also not a great
situation
at least I'm restricting the knights
still got my Alpha zero Pawn
King is now tied down to the bishop
okay so threatening take and take to hit
this and this
we might see rookie h i see F5
and getting off the e-file still
threatening take and take
and Bishop athletes
oh what to do G5
we all play King G2 first
also I'd if you thought of me when you
did the titled arena in Zen mode as I
gave you that idea but thank you either
way I enjoyed that LOL oh thanks for the
idea
I still got to post that one to you too
am I winning material
might be Queen D5 coming Rook here I
take and pin
oh there's this move defending
everything what
oppon's gonna find it
that move was not expected
okay now hitting this this and this
foreign
[Music]
okay
wasn't easy
I may play that three and really
regretted it
I just saw the funny line of trapping
the bishop
the video titled call an ambulance and
two hours later You released oh no my
queen oh really someone call an
ambulance I still haven't received any
royalties oh in Rosa no no don't sue me
don't don't sue me for a hundred million
dollars
I'll give you credit
oh was that coincidental I'll have to
watch her video
shout out to Josh everyone should sub to
Josh on YouTube
and on Twitch
makes amazing Scrabble content
and sometimes just content too
okay uh
E4
ooh tennis and Gambit
someone was asking for this earlier
I forgot who though
I already like this position
it feels nice
I've actually studied this exact
position this is a transposition of
another line where like block plays
Knight of six first
uh this shouldn't work because I can
take and then win F7
but I think
um
pretty sure I'm supposed to play Bishop
C4 here because there's lines where the
Knight gets trapped
Bishop C4 just cleanly wins upon
so this is a very successful Tennyson
I forgot who I was asking for this
earlier but I did see it
being asked for in chat
I'm not interested in the pollen there
um my Knight's getting trapped what to
do
and lived a good life
okay a lot of pressure against the
knights now
if I can take
I'll win this
I'm trying to imagine the quickest meat
let's put a knight on C5
so the b-pawn's defended
Rook wants to come in
so I want to set up like Bishop E5 and
then
backering meat
but I don't want to lose a knight
where is my mate
it's so close
check
is he fine just a tea Barrel bottom the
eighths that he actually stands for
treachery but Tennyson will work thanks
for that elegant warm graze I was a
thing duster who is asking for it
I hope Liverpool is treating you well
I gotta visit Liverpool someday I get I
keep hearing about it
that'll I missed a fork but I found a
pass Pawn
okay
GG
a nice Tennyson hey a hundred tournament
points
it's 67th Place
I'm sure the opponents will get more
difficult soon
I think I'll gradually play higher rate
players
playing spelling bee
quack
now there's been a few quacks today
welcome back to Kaka
uh oh let's wait a French
thank you anonymous
appreciate the anonymous bits
oh yeah elephant gamut too
but we're having a French here we might
have a two nights
I'll play a win over
I don't really play this line
F3 wow
yeah this is New Territory for me
I want to take and take but there's a
funny trap
I'll play C5
so I'm out of book and I was basically
out of the book on move one
uh but I the the great thing about like
having an understanding about Chess
sometimes you don't need to memorize
openings
you just need to
be able to see tactics
[Music]
um
I think the bishop is happier
I'll play this and this
it's happier to pressure the pawn
oh thanks so much ivanism
oh good morning to CDR Siri
from Rome
in Rome they say qua instead of quack
really
actually sounds more logical so I don't
think a duck can really pronounce
the k sound
also I'm up a piece but it doesn't feel
like I'm up a piece
what is this the F5
I guess because this Bishop's not doing
anything
I have to make the bishop do something
I'm allowing on person but then things
open up a little bit
yeah it's so passive here
I mean gradually I'll untangle like Nana
Fates
Bishop D7 Rook C8
I'm staying within my own territory
that takes a while for my pieces to
get out of their comfort zone
what Rose and his red sadness is blew
100 per hour I hope is enough for you
quack quack and all that
someone just donate twenty four hundred
dollars
I know that that's real
I even know that was like possible
what just happened
if that's real thank you so much I
appreciate it
that's insane
also I'm a little bit bedazzled my time
is ticking and I'm kind of speechless
all things for the quacks too
uh
okay I'm speechless a little bit but
let's try not to be paralyzed
I have to keep making moves
trying to win the night
I hope that wasn't a typo
but you even said a hundred dollars per
hour
what if it's my opponent trying to
uh
trying to distract me
does this mean I have to stream the
whole tournament then
to get in my hours
I'm so Bedazzled wait let me try and win
this game I don't want to lose my first
game of the tournament
I have 25 seconds
I'm up at peace I'll try and untangle
uh
let me really try it on Tango here
at least my heart rate is staying
relatively low
okay
hitting things
foreign
seconds
I also call her Bishops I have an extra
room well now my sub doesn't feel as
special quack oh I still think you're
special
you also have a special name
I'm so low on time
okay seven seconds to convert this
2400 deserves 24-hour stream yeah that's
true
wait
okay I've I think I have plenty of time
here
new ceiling traps
here yeah okay
okay
I have to calm down
thanks so much who's this mouse
[Music]
that's like that's probably the largest
don't know I've ever had
I really gotta calm down
okay
the the stream will continue
I'm really just speechless though
okay playing oh I'm playing a strong
player
we're gonna keep it going I mean I'm
I'll try and deliver on some
more good quality games
some fun content let's play a two nights
attack
E6
um
I'm trying to remember my prep I I
prepared this opening so seriously in
Gibraltar
for various opponents
I think
four
and D4 we trade
I'm still so flustered
I usually don't get flustered so easily
okay at least I'm not berserking this
game I have plenty of time to
chill take a deep breath
so H6 the pawn is pinned
do a video of highlights of each of the
24 hours
I mean I joined three hours late so I
have to make up for it right
uh
started playing OTB one by Checkmate in
21 moves with the pinova attack thanks
for everything that sounds fancy
uh welcome back bulkanosky chess
I don't even know what the oh the panel
of attack I know what that is
that's um C4 on move two against
Carolina I used to play that
I went through a phase of several years
ago
okay I probably didn't get a huge
opening Advantage from from this
or any opening advantage
I have this move
hi Eric knock knock who's there
okay I'm gonna allow the train looks
iffy but
also looks solid
thing industry says you should end the
stream immediately
oh yeah just to spend the twenty four
hundred dollars
foreign
I'm gonna I mean as long as I keep like
staying awake the stream will continue
and I guess if I fall asleep the stream
also continues
but I'll really try and stay awake I
mean
everyone's been doing a good job of
helping keep keep him awake so far
what will you buy with two thousand four
hundred
hmm
I haven't thought about it
maybe I'll just watch chat to sign
I'll take input from chat
what should I buy chat
wait let me let me Focus
and try and
not get too low on time
Goose hat oh I was gonna buy a duck
costume
I wanted to be a duck for Halloween
this is really not easy also like this
player has been me before
[Music]
um
King two King G3 maybe H4 later
it already feels like I'm a little bit
worse here
because my structure these double pawns
are not great
and G3 cons
I think I should shift over
to the file
hitting the pawn
foreign
like Bishop versus Knights
some imbalances with the structure
it should be close to equal and imagine
five may be coming
it's a question if I get the chance to
take do I actually want to take
I think I do actually
and Bishop wasn't that great
yeah it's still a little bit worse for
me
there's minority attack potential the
king should be on D3
and some H4 idea
so I might set up the Rooks on each file
play H4
minority attack is coming
I'm trying to trying to calculate like
takes and then A4
I mean there's other options
B3 is interesting
I don't know what to do
okay weird move a king B3 idea
that didn't really make any sense let's
go back
it should still be close to equal
I think I'm okay with a draw like
if that's what it comes to
I'd still like to play for a win though
it's just not easy
okay after the pawn
hey it's me Eric two thousand four
hundred dollars is enough to buy around
192 ducks or enough ducks to fill three
chessboards wait a real doctor yes quack
uh
okay intense time scramble coming
I know who's playing for a win
by playing for a win
by Punk gets low on time I'm playing for
wind
and it's very close to being a draw
so black is playing for a win
a good move
I'm in trouble
foreign
I got a dirty flag I mean
it's a position I play out anyway to try
and like stalemates but
uh wow
okay
I'm getting some cardio for uh for the
Stream
um yeah I mean black was clearly pushing
for a win I was ready to repeat
uh when we were just defending the ratio
improves when you're awake rather than
asleep
I guess that's true right
but it can also
like what's the opposite of improve it
can also get worse
really depends but it has been improving
the last several games
[Music]
yeah I mean you always have to play up
upon because there's sometimes even
tricks where I can force a rook trade
uh which is kind of what happened
um although my king would need to be in
front of the pong
like already here like King H4 Rook G4
and then the kings called off it's still
a drill of course
okay back to tournament I gained four
points for that
Four Points was like the most I've
gained from any game
so I I played 26 games so far
96 win rate
I'm berserking for some reason let's
play a um they call this a black Mustang
only kind of pre-move the opening there
this is like a reverse Brooklyn defense
so is white playing the Brooklyn attack
realizing this Knight's a little bit
misplaced
oh
okay Bishop here is an idea
F2 is vulnerable here like Knight G4 and
just some quick attack could be very
effective
that's a good move though
uh what to do
I think I should take and then Bishop B6
I'm just looking at some line H3 Bishop
F5
also I'm just attacking this Pawn I
forgot about
okay so white defends I attack so
Knights attacked undefended and it's
tied down to the pawn
so it's kind of unstable
clever
I'm winning anything
I mean I could win the pawn I guess
I wanted more of it but
you have to be realistic
I have to hold on to my time
50 first place
it's still going to be really hard to
catch up to the top spot
okay Knight D3 is an idea I think C6 is
just safer though
this is a really nice structure to have
against a nylon C3 and also a bishop on
the long diagonal
I don't want to give up the bishop so
easily
like Bishop
I have Bishop C2
almost works
I think I'll play this first
this move coming
I'm moving way too slowly
uh G5
Rook B8 Maybe
I have 41 seconds
okay so the threat I think is Bishop B4
never mind
okay now there's some um because my Rook
is on B I might have Bishop C2
but the lines are messy it's 97
it does too tricky to calculate
let's go up upon
okay it's important the things defended
because
allows for Knight C4
oh wait I have this one though
completely forgot that was hanging
thankfully it's not so bad I don't think
time is still not great
it's a good move
[Music]
a risky decision
okay that was really risky from lights
interesting
another one of these
I think I'm gonna win though easy
pre-moves
I could probably win with still having
over five seconds
never mind
okay Maiden mate next move okay
wow well it came that was really close
I was close to getting dirty flagged
probably because of karma from that
previous game
oh man
okay
thank you dog lover
okay 17 hours left
foreign
43rd Place
now the Wednesday continues
I had that one draw earlier
okay
[Music]
um
okay back to back to chess
um let me go for a Cambridge Springs
again
I played this at least one game earlier
and it worked out pretty well
to be fair earlier I was playing like a
lower rate of player
but here
um
yeah I can still apply the same ideas
and takes and then C5
and we get um yeah we get a position
where I have the bishop here things are
a bit more open I think Bishop E7 makes
sense
okay I have a funny story to tell after
this game about this exact position
um
but I'll tell it after this game
create some suspense
Bishop D3
so E5
I think G6 actually makes sense
just so I don't have to worry about this
battery
and then Queen
I want to do some E5 move
thinking Asics first
ah maybe I can take and then play E5
uh thank you Kavita gifting to Jeffrey
appreciate that
I'm just trying to like think clearly
I'm realizing like I'm having some
like foggy mind right now
just have to power through it
Bishop
Bishop G7
now Bishop E6
okay Rooks are gonna come in
visible G7 F5 coming
that's a reasonable move
yeah if I don't think I want to open the
B file for white
I could play Rook p8 though
it's also questionable
I have a funny idea Rook fb8 it looks so
strange
but like assuming white takes on V6 my
Rook wants to stay on the a file
now maybe bishop G7
trying to get ready to play F5 like
takes and then F5 and E4
that's a fine move
Bishop B3
that's not so easy
also getting low on time
my Rook is misplaced why did I put my
Rook on B8
I play H6
it's no good though
if I take
I think I'll take
I didn't calculate this fully but
looks like a reasonable option
um
D7
I'm in trouble
ah
I'd even berserk this game but I'm still
in some trouble
because it's it's equal material I'm
gonna have bad structure white has good
Bishop good Rook battery I'm like barely
holding on to things
maybe I'll turn on pentatonic later
[Music]
but for now yeah I don't want to get too
sleepy myself
I'm staying alive here actually obstacle
your Bishops
bring the king to the center
um
trying not to lose a pawn
I mean this is such a sad Bishop though
like what to do
you know I'll offer a trade this is
basically a draw offer
yeah good choice
yeah I'm hitting upon the B5 Bishop B4
and then all of a sudden there could be
counter play
I mean there's also play for whites
I want to play Rook D2 but
I think it was too risky
keep my Rook defending
okay down what about 40 seconds
good move
I'm taking King G5
King should go back
still some trouble
okay this is now a draw
depends how much why he wants to torture
me
uh uh I have to take a draw
okay
my second draw of the turnings
not the end of the world
I do lose my streak
of like terminal points but I don't lose
my undefeated streak
so yeah that could have gone a bit more
wrong
why not take on F3
not sure if I have a chance oh much
later
um
the bishop defended
yeah the distant Bishop defense
induction would be fine to like take and
then put a duck on F or on e4 D5
but not in normal chest
so I want to share a quick
tidbits about the opening that we just
went into
so it's been a goal of mine for a while
to make a new chess course
of some sorts and I figured
it's best to
just kind of get feedback on what people
want a course about and then try and
make like a high quality
uh
products of of something that would um
that would be instructive that people
can learn from
um so I have this Google form
that has almost 100 submissions
and I'll go ahead and share it on
screen
and I'm sharing the responses too so
like uh
one person wants a course on Kung Fu
chess tactics
uh which maybe can be made by someone
else who knows tactics better than me
getting emotions in check
but the majority of of uh
people seem to want openings and
strategy slash positional play
um
and then scrolling down
because I think it's likely I want to
make an opening course like that's
generally my area of expertise
uh so there's there's a question what
openings would you be interested in
getting a course on
and
the most voted for response oh God this
is updating live too
I have to be careful what I show though
um
it seems like most people want a course
On a Block rapid tour against D4
and then
I also have a submission for reading so
just to get a sense of what like who the
target audience is
so I actually started
kind of making the skeleton of a course
and just to give a small taste
I was working earlier on the Cambridge
Springs
um
file
like a PGN file this is this is just a
starting point like I really just
scratched the surface
but I was looking at this specific line
earlier today
maybe about uh about 12 hours ago
so I guess technically yesterday for me
um but the line that I just played
in my game
I was analyzing uh Bishop takes F6
Bishop D3 Bishop B4 Queen C2 takes takes
E5
actually the queen was on B3 right
this game
oh no the queen was on C2
so if we look at this position that I
just had
and then look here
same exact position
train
and um
yeah I've been
I've been trying to like put together a
collection of lines that are like easily
digestible easy to understand will give
you like practical positions that
um
that you'd be excited to play
and I was happy to like discover this
variation of Cambridge Springs because
like black has a bishop here relatively
open Center and then there is a funny
trap after 94.
um there's actually a game that I was
looking at
we have the same position though right
Bishop E7
oh yeah this is still crap
so the main deviation was uh
yeah Rook ac1 was played in this
analysis
and
there's a funny track coming up black
played G6 in this game too
and then in this position
[Music]
maybe I'll leave this as a
puzzle
for chat but this is black to move and
win
and in the game that I found which was
actually a correspondence game black did
not find the winning move
see one suggestion for Rook C5 or Rook
takes E4
which isn't necessary
Bishop B5 is kind of off limits because
tonight
but good job to everyone saying Pawn E5
is just a really nice resource
attacking the queen attacking the Knight
but also discover defending the bishop
and it just wins a piece
very multi-purpose Fork
thank you to curious Mountain crawler
appreciate the five gifted
anyway
um
this is going to be one of the main
focuses for me actually in the coming
like a week or two is to expand a ton on
these files I'll probably give more
previews
um and also get kind of input into
um
Maybe
different types of variations I should
be covering
thank you sameen
and I want to make this like thorough
but also like not too overwhelming so
it's kind of a fine line to ride
but anyway just wanted to share that I
do appreciate wow
earlier there was less than 100
responses
now there's 119 responses so thank you
everyone for giving feedback there is
this place uh for like additional
comments
oh dear look at these additional cons
duck duck quack quack quack quack also
quack
I really appreciate the feedback from
all the Ducks
here we go let's join
oops
yeah tournament like this I think it's
important to take breaks
oh and and berserk back okay I'll desert
back
so we have a
almost a bullet game in two and a half
minutes it's fast Blitz
so Mainline London
and queen C5 is already slightly
inaccurate
so the main idea here is to go for a
quick uh Queen side expansion
yeah very quick development Rook C1 can
come very soon
and queen should probably go to E2
throwing in B4
nothing so special just yet black might
go for The Rook shift
unpleasant time situation E4 is an idea
it's a fairy move
not entirely sure what my plan is
making sure my Rook isn't blocked
go for Knight C4
wow
confusing move
okay it's important to stay up on time
also important not to plunger anything
I might go for a queen trade at some
point like Knight ce5
oh there's G4
G4
let's do it
I'm not H2 or Bishop H2
okay I think everything is under control
[Music]
E5 oh E5 is interesting though
I want to take but then Rook D2 in the
end
uh where's my trick Bishop C2 Maybe
so counter-attacking the Knight
yeah if I took an E5 there's takes takes
in this
I have to be very very careful
wow
Bishop H7
start with this
I'm down a pawn
so if takes I take and win the bishop
the new gameplay TV
okay now I can yeah
let's take here and then take here
wow It's Tricky position
we're both getting very low on time
uh
get this move defending
defending
oops
what should I do
I think it's no it's not okay
or is it
oh no
no
I think it's gonna be my first loss
once a miracle happens
Dole
it was my first loss oh no my rating oh
no my streak
oh wow how did I let that happen
I just got I've lost a knight also
another game started oops no time to
recover
okay
let me try and
let me try and recover wait what is this
line does this work
I feel like I should know this
uh oh
wait what is this what is this position
at least I have time to think now
um I'm gonna win the night so it's not
that bad I don't think
It's Tricky though
I wonder if it makes sense to play no no
Knight of Three is coming I have to take
King takes
okay
so what's the damage what was this
position
um I'm down
no it's it's equal material I have a
rook or I have knighted in two pawns for
a rook
maybe it's not even so bad like each
five
in D5
open the bishop
foreign
I just realized Rook G7 is a threat wow
I really didn't think that was so so
dangerous
maybe it's not
like keeps things covered
okay defending
I have a really bad feeling about this
I still don't think it's so bad though
like Queen here rookcha King G7
I'm kind of pinned on the back rank
but I'm not getting muted
hmm
it's just a question how do I get out of
this
annoying bind
like if I take
I really want a sack but
how to do this
okay my plan is to play C6 A5 Rook A6 or
maybe Rook a seven Knight A6
yeah I'm really stuck here
although this is a free Pawn right
everything in life is free
where's Clearwater
clear water
my water that I'm drinking isn't so
clear
but it's really good
really nice sencha
oh Clearwater Florida
I've been to Florida a few times
I don't think I've been to Clearwater
though
okay I have this move
which probably ends badly for me
uh check
I think Bishop G3
it's actually a fascinating position the
bishop is like an attacker and Defender
and there's just weird geometry
the fact that I'm pinned the Bishop
defensive Rook Queen defends a bishop
play this move
and now my Bishop defends a knight which
is
it could be important
if I want to like lift my Rook later
hmm
I'm still really not sure how to handle
this
a new C5
going for the spacecraft
wait this is not good
to take with King
this
I'm Holding On by a thread
and this could very well be my second
loss
and D5 is fine
and this move
attacking everything
I'm just trying to create confusion now
oh no
I'm the one getting confused
[Music]
okay I'm down there Rook
I'm actually really curious about this
opening
okay I'm gonna lose the game but at
least I'll learn something about the
opening hopefully
uh
I don't know what to do I just want to
give a check
I also want to take the Rook
you never know
I should probably resign now though
okay I'll resign
I held off losing for so long losing two
games in a row let's analyze this
opening though it was actually a cool a
cool line
so F4
is considered bad
but not because it takes oh wow so this
is this is playable
fg3 Bishop G2 okay
so there's some Theory here
fast move Queen C4 what
and then takes
and D5
okay I learned something
that's a cool way of playing the Polish
it's super risky
so next time I should just play this and
it takes
wow Knight G4
I have three
this crazy engine way of playing ampa
song
what if what if H3
93
oh that's kind of cool
and then you just leave the Knight here
and play this that's insane
983 Knight C6
deep opening prop
we could also take and take
wow okay
okay I'm learning learning something new
every law should teach you at least one
lesson
that's one way to overcome tilt
okay berserk raging is also another way
to
overcome to alter
play into the tilt
okay
yeah assuming I make this
um
this facing 1d4 course
I will be covering this line
against the London it's a fun line
um
I think I can play 95 right away
this is more positional there's actually
like a really famous game
uh who was a capablanca
where he played also do I have this move
look at this move
I think it works
Bishop B5 Knight E7
I mean Bishop G7 as well
I mean Bishop D7
I just uh smothered trapped The Rook
it's like the smothered pin drop
yeah this is another way to overcome
tilt
and get a funny tactic
now now we just trade everything
[Music]
and The Rook is more powerful than the
Knight
threatening this
so I'm going in to trap the bishop in
two different ways
yeah like covers it
no mercy
oh I missed I have a chance for no I
didn't have a chance for D4
foreign
okay a few more moves
or no more moves okay trying to work my
way back to
2600.
top 50.
over 10 000 players in this tournament
wow
playing this person
I want to mix up the openings
um
I should take opening recommendations
again
oh yeah I won't connect for that
previous game
oh yes my rosin trophy I don't think
I've played a real Smith Mora yet
okay we have something that resembles
ponziani it's more of an elephant
Sicilian
um let's take
yeah this is a really bad line for black
now the line I played was kind of
dubious but uh
yeah this is supposed to be really good
for whites
this is one of the few things I know in
the Allerton
um I assume Bishop B5 first
and there's some funny Queen F3
and how does block defend meat
hey it's just dojo
shout out to just dojo
welcome to the Stream
if you're just joining I'm playing the
Autumn Marathon
it's a 24 hour long tournament
uh my opponent just walked into some
funny opening
I'm trying to
just finish off this game
like I want to take
I could take and then take
this isn't so simple though
because The Bishop's hanging C3 is
hanging
so I might be better off
I have a simple idea I'm just going to
take on D7 First Take on F7
and then move back to F3 that way I
defend I defend
I attack
this looks really good for lights
okay lock defense
little castle
you know top 10 is probably within reach
but it takes a lot of grinding
and just have to be patient keep my
composure
stay awake it's also kind of important
I'm trying to imagine on poisson
checkmate
that would be a nice Frozen jewelry
let's just meet in two
E6 only legal move
okay
that was nice
yeah this line this line is dubious next
T3
um
black should take first I believe
taking here first is a mistake it looks
good for black at first but at D5 and
White's doing really well
okay nice game
trying to get back on track
uh nope is working
I'll play
I think every game against D4 I'll just
play what I plan to make a course on
is like the Cambridge Springs repertoire
this is also the elephant trap
and we still haven't addressed the
elephant in the room
but uh that's okay
White's not falling into it
Cambridge Springs time
it's a tricky opening
most players like above 2300 should be
familiar with it but it's still kind of
um it has some surprise value
that's one of the things I like about it
yeah Bishop D3 is actually like the main
trap
like why does now
light is lost upon Bishop B4
hitting a lot of things
so I'm up upon it's probably not that
bad for lights
white has the two Bishops I have this
kind of lesser impressive Bishop
but a pawn is upon position simplified a
bit
uh I'd probably like to maneuver the
bishop
to F7 or maybe G6
yeah G6 is actually a really nice Square
um yeah five is intention
if I take
I also Knight D5
there's also this move which is doesn't
work at all
uh what to do
A5 A4
so Knight D5
takes
Yeah the more I'm looking at Bishop G6
some more I think it makes sense
that five I take
worst case scenario like I put a 995
there's a line uh like rookie one check
I'll have to move back to f8
and then
when Bishop F6 is played
I can take first
so I think everything's okay here
and it still takes a lot of work though
I'm probably gonna lose back upon
um like 95 now
I want to take
[Music]
with the Rook too
and take a rook
yeah so the bishop has to move
he saddens the threat
uh rookie seven still coming
King f8
and what else to do
okay so I have this move
I have this move to
this is gonna be like a weird opposite
color Bishop ending this could be a
really long game
I want to win this Pawn
I'm still up a pawn install things to
the opening
but this is where endgame skills come
into play
probably A5
uh man it's so close to meat
Chuck
okay this
is risky playing my king on the edge
um
shouldn't be taking so long
I shouldn't be blundering either
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
pays off okay
oh man
I'm sure things were missed but
yeah these positions can be very
deceiving like they look simple but
they're really not
okay
minus six plus two
doesn't that defy physics
what's that law
thermodynamics
top 40.
jinx
okay uh
uh what openings were being requested
earlier
I haven't played the jobava London yet
there's gotta be someone that wants to
bother London
okay jobava London
uh but we have we have this move order
which is a little bit different
but still a very jobava like
yeah Zen mode and guess ELO maybe will
come later
not a bad idea
but I want to raise my standing a little
bit
uh Bishop E2
I really haven't like leaned back like I
play this whole tournament leaning
forward
not taking advantage of the like
cushioning of my chair
this is slightly more comfy now
what to do
I'll move the Knight somewhere
this is actually a problem Pawn
like G3 looks hideous but
V for victory
okay Knights
hmm
right here
we're going to trade a little bit
I mean this Knight is still very much
out of play
and like goes back I fork
F6 might come and then I have to figure
out what I'm doing
although it's not really threatening
anything
[Music]
Bishop's actually safe as long as these
pawns stay where they are
wow
okay Rook D1
I think I'm winning the pawn now
and D file battery is pretty strong
Knight C7 we could trade I win the pawn
it's still like an end game grind but
it's a spot that I'm happy with
so black wants to win upon two
I think I'm okay with that like Queen
here I played Knight G6
rookie seven
like there's almost a tactic where I
play this
and this Pawn is pinned to The Rook
so let's take let's take the Knight
I'm not sure what's happening after this
move though
like I almost have this funny move
like crazy tactics
I'm also looking at this crazy
so I play this there's Pawn takes
but if I play this
uh then takes I'd fork and I'm up a rook
foreign
position
[Music]
so wait Knight see it
the point is I'm threatening Rook G6
which is hilarious I'm also leaving my
queen rook and night hanging which is
insane but
like I think this just works
it's so funny
by Queen rook and Knight are all on
ridiculous squares
but the weird tactical geometry
it's so pleasing
am I just losing a no I'm average G6
for a moment I didn't know what to do
after King I faith
and King f8 Rook here and
it should be enough to win
thank you jimbly
happy three months
oh how many people are a lot of people
speaking French in the chat
no hablo francais
there is someone that said bonjour from
the U.S
yeah how many people are watching from
America
it's 302 am Central Time
so I'm up one Pawn
but Black's King side is in shambles
threatening this
black defended everything
but not this
okay do I try and like be instructive
and show the kingpon engine
I'm not sure if the kingpong ending is
winning though it should be
there's no reason to go for it
like I might as well win more pawns
first
like Queen G5
forcing King f8 and then I'll take on C5
okay now I can I can happily go into
kingpong ending
yeah
okay that was a fun game
let this move Knight C8
I think it's probably the best move too
unless Knight of five Knight five is the
same idea
but then takes
no
let's see
let's see it is up there
Queen B7 I didn't consider
wow everything's the same evaluation
so I found one of the best moves
okay let's move on
back to tournaments
oh it's 3 P.M in Thailand oh wow that's
like the other side of the world
how many people are watching from Asia
where it's like a normal time and
there's probably sunlight
so I just realized my green screen is a
little bit off
inside
like the chroma key filter seemed off
there maybe it's not too bad though
okay uh playing
let's play like a normal Queen's Pawn
opening
just like Beth Harmon
except not quite a Queen's Gambit
okay I'm gonna play with hanzim and play
against Ray Robson and Bishop F4
is a funny line
they didn't go into this so this is a
queen's Indian
um I actually know this position
usually comes from a different move
order
but
yeah this is some Theory actually I
think D6
I have the black side of this position
the 20 I think it was 2013 or 2014
Chicago open
I was back against your malinsky
and he he played Bishop D3 and said oh
no my Pawn
and then he castled and said oh no my
van
Point not taking the pawn
I'm still offering the g-pawn
um
it's okay to bring the Knight back
a night
and this Knight wants to have some fun
though
and this Pond isn't takeable because I
have Bishop H7 in the end
wow
always play King B1
yeah I want to play like H4
engage four makes sense here
I was even thinking some Knight G5
I'm just trying to make sense of how the
tactics could play out
Bishop H7 there's some resources
takes takes
not expecting that move
and this looks really good now
this is a free attack
Bishops versus Knights
opponents letting me on the song
I don't think I want to take on F6 this
is by far the better capture
foreign
I mean this diagonal is uh
the one to try and exploit
I think this move
Queen C3 is now a massive threat if I
play Queen C3 first there's D5
but I don't see how black deals with it
or maybe that's how
I mean there's still this pin
this Knight has almost no moves there's
Knight C8
I think the plan is just to gradually
build up pressure like bring the rook in
so Bishop H4 Knight C8
starting with this
yeah problem for black is a king can't
really move off the diagonal
only legal King movies King G7
and I'm ready
what am I ready to do
F4
I want to play this
and one more attacker
yeah ambassan isn't actually focused a
lot of people have been fooled by
mobs on the internet
okay that was a nice game
um
yeah I lost like a very similar game uh
when I was younger to your moon ski
and then he made
he made like a whole video recapping our
game
for the internet chess club he had a
series called
something called every Russian Schoolboy
knows
maybe there's some people watching who
know what I'm talking about
but um the video is somewhere on the
internet of him talking about this line
okay
so I played 35 games so far
I've lost
two rating points this whole tournament
berserk rate 54 percent
not berserking this game
playing Papa Pizza
A3 wow
trying to understand 83
so it's useful in the sense like in some
of these lines
um
wondering if I can just develop
if I take
hmm
like I'm out of my main crap
it's trying to figure out
uh loose line
I think I want to play Knight H5 at some
point let's just Castle
okay I have to play this
so 94 and Knight H5 are both moves
movie 94.
the idea is to get a stone wall set up
on support the knights
uh
it's not super comfortable but
I'll try and make it work like B6 at
some point
G4 might be coming
it's usually why white plays H3
and there's G5 for me which is
interesting
oh Gary loves pizza in the chat
but rooting against the pizza oh
could use a slice of pizza right now
you'll also use an E5 break
this Pawn has been backwards for a while
okay
this move gives me a little bit more
freedom
it's kind of like I just turned 18 I can
vote
I can
what else can I do
you can buy property
I can develop my Bishop
it's still kind of a sad mission
so there's an idea to play Rook E8 and
then take on F2 and then take on E3
can legally represent myself yeah
foreign
G5
and G5 looks fun
but not yet
G6 first
yeah the point of G6 is to like
gradually build up like King G7 H6
ensuring the night won't happen
I really have to keep in mind this move
I'm going for G5
wow
if I take
I mean F5
it's an idea
oh where's my idea
takes
you should start with A5
it's like crazy crazily solid for lights
we trade everything on B1 I win C5
C5 is a liability for lights
some might see three idea
um
okay light squares are very juicy now
but there's a lot of Trades
take
start with this
I assume the trade favors me
and especially now I have this move
still not so simple
you can't allow the queen to come in
so I think I start with this
the pawn can't be defended
it's still really tricky
foreign
I think this idea is actually really
nice
B3
I think B3 should just be winning
I had to choose between two attractive
ideas
I mean I assume there's no Perpetual
after Queen C7 I queen
D6 king queen G6 King f8
and then the queen can come back after
Queen H6
that move I forgot about
thankful I have this move
yeah Queen h8 from corner to corner
or from B1 to H1
depending what light does
uh where's the horse meat
I don't see Force means
and keenly weirdly survives
what did I just allow
I mean white had A7 there
maybe not
okay
okay
hey it's pizza that's pizza [ __ ] to
celebrate I should order some pizza I
don't know if any pizza places are open
at 3 20 am I imagine there's got to be
some
24-hour pizza places
thank you Gary
I'll hold off I still got my Essentia
my back over hey I'm back over 2600
let's go
so only two losses so far
137 tournament points
31st Place
oh yeah Domino's is probably
an option
okay muscle memory is taking over
between games I'll I'll look at chat for
opening requests
is Domino's Pizza that's probably a
valid question
thank you Shannon Rubin
happy six months
also happy opening trial
as a very common London opening drop
that even strong players fall for
except it sounds so simple here because
Queen B6
um
yeah thankfully I'll have Bishop A3
so I should hold on to the pawn
yeah generally I'm not a big fan of um
especially fast food pizza
higher quality Pizza I'm um
I enjoy
there's a pizza place in St Louis
which is supposedly one of Obama's
favorite pizza places
a Pie Pizzeria
short walk from the chess club
been there many times
good quality Pizza
um
yeah I think this just calls for
patients
I'll probably like gradually build up E4
thanks for the endless YouTube content
that helps me keep beating my friend up
oh you're welcome sorry to your friend
oh thanks so much siren k
I'm very kind though now
and so much to put towards this pizza
fund
I had um I think the last time I had
dominoes was in Gibraltar
and it was edible
but there there were just better food
options
okay let's play H4
fun position here
uh Knight wants to come to F5
I think I'll play F3 and Bishop F2
a simple solution
I think A3 is an important move
otherwise black was going to play A3
so both pawns attacked
now both pawns defended
foreign
being up upon
I think at some point maybe bishop H3
and G4
black being very sneaky
maybe I can start with this
you have to be patient here
gradually build up
like The Rook here
so then
like it's important to note that the B
file is the only file with no pawns on
it so the only fully open file
it makes sense to just create a triple
battery on that file
okay block doubling up as well
F4
let's start with this
foreign
[Music]
yeah it's a very closed position so it
calls for just a lot of maneuvering
which I'm okay with like this Knight
wants to go here
so
starting with Bishop D2
and
trying to get a knight G4 if H5 that
allows Bishop G5
maybe still G4 coming
because the time finally arrived
to move my g-pawn
and play this first
I'm such a nice word for The Rook
okay the time has arrived
wow Bishop F6
um
why does my knight want to go it's F4
okay so this is a path
sometimes positions like this is just
about like figuring out the ending
points
and then working your way through the
maze
gonna trade all the Rooks
and keep a pair of Rooks on the board
okay so the the pressure point is uh in
G6
I think that F4 is a simple approach
hey it's stockfizz welcome back
good to see you hope you're doing well
happy 43 months
for everyone joining I am a little bit
sleep deprived
but I'm trying to stay strong
[Music]
trying to win material
use my Pawns
my keyboard was next to the mouse so the
mouse like ran into the keyboard
that could have been tragic
this Pawn still undefended
takes takes
I mean
this should just be winning
like even if black has a few extra moves
this is basically a meeting attack like
two two pass pawns and the three minor
pieces
there's gonna be mating patterns
but where's the meat
I'm not seeing the mage
okay I guess a rook will come in
black resisted
for a little bit
these pieces don't really help defend
the king
okay nice game
yeah that kind of stumbled into this
opening
um
which I think could have been okay like
either either CD4 first or queen B6
first
still tricky
okay yeah tell me what openings to play
I can consider playing uh orangutan
what's the other one that was
mentioned earlier
something about pizza
Halloween gadgets okay
the egg is actually playable against
Knight F3 I could play the egg
I'll play the egg okay
assuming my opponent allows
G4
this was played in like a serious
tournament
by Brandon Jacobson who at the time I
think he was like
maybe strong I am
pretty sure we're following the game I
forgot who he was playing though
Maybe Christian carrilla
I'm playing the egg
um it's not so bad
let's move seven and neither of us have
any pieces developed
mostly pushing pawns each tree is a good
move
H3 is actually a little bit problematic
for me
not entirely sure what to do
like
I want to defend
if I want to scanned it
foreign
some weird like E5 or C5
Queen F6 is interesting
Bishop H6
and Bishop H6
it's like some weird
sequences of moves like for example if
takes
I think
oh no I can't take back
takes here I think I take on C1
I'm realizing Bishop H6 was probably
just a bad move
oh what to do
try and cut my losses
attacking two pawns now
I do consider Bishop G7 the problem with
G4 would still hang
and like I wouldn't have time to take on
D4 because G would hang
okay
that's a good move
completely Nissan move
thinking queen queen E7
[Music]
I'm gonna try and just play quickly here
and G5 is probably coming
foreign
oh I have some uh
rescuing to do
my whole position needs rescuing
this is a really bad egg
I can't even play the bad because I
don't have a b-pong
good move
yeah my Knight's like stuck forever
but hopefully my spirits aren't stuck
forever
see five
I wanna play F5 and duck F6 but I don't
have a duck
okay five
I always played this really well so far
I'm just gonna Turtle up
we probably D5 at some point like D5 C5
I'm somehow up on time
have to use whatever Advantage I can get
a free Pawn
a nice gift
yeah sometimes it's a matter of
hunkering down and waiting for
opportunities or waiting for unexpected
gifts
it's still not great because now the B
file is open and my books can't connect
easily
92 is probably coming
probably D5 now
and then my Rook will like go back and
hide
yeah like the the setup is so bad
uh let's just hide
Turtle time
no work trainer
I want to attack this Pawn like this is
an idea
oh dear Knight C5 is coming
am I a pawns hanging
okay Queen d8 and then do I still have
casting rights I don't think I've moved
my king or each Rook
and my King's not tied down to the
bishop at least I have this idea
one active attacking move maybe each
four coming to
wow
so claustrophobic
I have no moves
foreign
also threatening to take
interesting
there's a weird repetition that we might
go into the game might end with Knight
B7 Knight C5 King g87
I think it's coming
okay that one I didn't expect
now I'm actually alive
I wonder if my opponent missed uh Queen
d8
it's still tricky because
this Pawn
but it's not as bad like I I can breathe
do the snow
light is so tricky
like this
okay
I think I survived the worst of it
it's gonna be a time scramble
good night's trout
okay wow
ah
I got a rose and true view of that for
that game
I have one with the egg
I don't know if it was worth it
all the pain
and discomfort
man
hey two reading points
okay let's go
top 30. out of over 11 000 players
that's a very eccentric opening
well bizarre
try and use this momentum
if Knight F6 I'll play another egg
only if Knight F6
ceiling time
I'll go back to my usual
uh we'll play Mainline Grand Prix
or not
entirely sure what this is
excellent hmm
thank you Phil stew
okay some reasonably direct plan
there's actually a lot of attacking
potential here
I have five ideas
yeah so I have the bishop pair
in the E5
still some attacking potential
uh
[Music]
uh I want to play this and then
eventually Bishop F4
okay
realizing this is something to be a
little bit concerned about
okay everything's still under control
though
Bishops are nice we might see D4 at some
point
probably not right away
and time is good
wow
wow
now these pawns are menacing
oh
come down upon
up on time
a wise move
hmm
A very wise move
how to do this
foreign
probably this move
okay one was a possibility rookie one's
still a move
it's not
uh
I have six ideas
not easier for blocks to break through
time is ticking
Simple Plan
foreign
opponent really gifted me some material
towards the end there
gifts of the queen and then the Rook
okay
GG
got the berserking points keeping the
streak
25th Place
oh
okay staying alive
it's one way to stay awake
an opponent berserking back nice
oh
um
um yeah the proper approach here is to
sagon B2
and then go for E4
I Do cover this in my London chorus
of G3
V6 is slightly unusual
okay leaving tension
yeah there's some like Rook
Rook B3 to H3 idea
um I have six coming
can I go all out for the sack Bishop H7
and G5
I don't think it works
what might work is this first
I don't know this is very speculative
it's interesting though
and then Queen H5
now this doesn't work uh
it doesn't
if here I can take
this might actually be like really cool
I've only has to think too so I'm
gaining some precious time
that move like for completely forgot
about
that's a move
wow
uh
oh
take take
good move
I'm in trouble
I'm just down the piece
I tried to be overly clever it backfired
now I have to suffer
it's still interesting though because
there's
an arrow
I have a few arrows
I'm like F4 no F4 is not legal my phone
was pinned
I want to play H4 I just want to like go
all out
YOLO
H5 coming
I could move
allowing the trade but what else to do
and to cut off the queen
C3 at some point
a gray move
there's our five
okay
[Music]
um
foreign
thing
I'm winning I might be winning this
it's a miracle
I don't know how that happened
oh look at this breakthrough I think F6
is just winning for fights because takes
the pawn can't be stopped what a miracle
breakthrough
yeah I'll actually play F6 here just
close things down
wow what a swindle
yeah G5 was like crucial to set this up
now here's a crazy question
is F6 so only no there's other moves
there's a king here there's probably
Bishop A4
um just to verify though
a bunch of winning moves
oh it's still waiting for Bach
Bishop D5
Bishop E4 what
how's Bishop E4 winning
take
wow
that's like an endgame stuff GG and
great Marathon oh thank you G's face
look at this King takes E4
King E6
it just looks like White's winning but
after F5 check
King has to move back and king gets back
and time in this panel Queen
was the other winning move
oh yeah Bishop D5 is also kind of crazy
just like very chill and it takes on F5
H6 Bishop G8 blocks just in time
and some crazy lines there
but like in a game when you have 11
seconds left I mean finding Bishop E4 or
Bishop D5 that's that's very difficult
okay back to tournament the win streak
continues
23rd Place
um top 10 is within sight
still takes work
okay playing classical chess
but actually playing Blitz chess
I haven't played the Stafford in a while
and the Stafford will have to wait
oh we have a
um Rusev
only taking time though
it was basically a scotch Gambit
we'll see my opponent's prep
are we gonna see Magnuson
actually I prepared the black side of
Magnuson
against Canty for our match we didn't go
into it though
this is a line and queen D7 is a
important move
for Bishop E7
F5 I know F5 is supposed to be played at
some point
uh it's probably some tricky line
what
am I walking into like opening prop
so if I take
uh Bishop G5 so if I take here
up Exchange
I like the fact that White's taking time
at least
kind of C5
5 is kind of scary wow
um
it still looks okay
Queen here I have this
now C5
still really tricky
I'd like to attack the Fisher
I was trying to assess like 95 I can
take Queen C4 Queen E6
takes I take
and the tension remains
could now probably see five
and what is this position
B5 takes and then C4
thank you uh the new sub
very tricky position here
it's a weakening move but what else to
do
I think I'll sack back the exchange
okay
oh no
okay
still alive down the pond
anyway has one move here
not sure why White's taking time
93 was only move
like this
oh
that's not good
getting all played
oh
well played
oh no my streak
oh no my Bishop
uh
okay GG
oh let me check the openings
I doubt that was actual prep
but a still tricky position to play
95 was fine
ah Rook F6 yeah there's better ways to
get back to exchange
once I give it back like that it's um
the table's turned
white played well
okay hey I'm back to 2600.
my readings really it's like stayed the
same throughout this whole tournament
pretty much
playing the person in fourth place
it would be nice to reach top 10.
it takes patience though
we'll still have some energy
okay so I'm playing
um a very harmonious setup
there is a book I had when I was younger
it was
something about the English opening
it was a big a book by karpov I was
supposed to be like a book on how to
play the English as white
but you spent a while like sharing like
his thoughts about the sign
and like he's played the setup maybe
similar setups as black
not symbol to play like pieces all have
nice homes
Bishop can develop Rooks will come in
did my watch die oh my watch I need to
charge my watch
uh the heart rate has been oops
heart rate's been stuck at 82 for a
while
how long has it been like that
oh dear
okay Queen C7
yeah I think the bishop will return to
C8
okay the idea is an ig3
it's very tempting to just take
like super tempting
I think I'll do it
because Queen H4 is pretty much
Unstoppable
and
the reason I'm going for this is uh the
power of the bishop
because it's so hard for white to
resolve the issues here
we might see this and this but then F2
becomes weak
there's actually some funny line like
imagine never mind
that's a good move
I think I want to trade
I could move the H Pawn
huh
I'm tempted to sack more
sock on E3
actually this line looks okay so it
takes takes Knight G3 Queen H3
Queen F3 Knight H4 Queen H1 Queen G4
foreign
this is like I saw this line initially
in
for some reason I didn't see Queen G4
right away but now the thread is Knight
F3
I'm also threading this
pod is overworked
and this queen is just in the corner
kind of
kind of stuck
oh but are we just gonna draw
forget about Queen E4 I have this move
we'll always repeat once
I don't think I'm gonna take a draw I
think I'm gonna play for a win
's bullet rating
one has a highball rating
I was curious given their username
yeah no draw
going for the win
it's risky I'm down a piece here
white has an extra night liking with a
pawn
although takes takes takes I take on
uh E3 really
I also have D5 which is kind of
interesting
I mean it's at least a draw but I'll
have a rook lift
so it takes takes King H1 check here
lift my Rook
looks good
wow I completely miss that move I have
this move
I also have this move
I also have this move
that's when he moves
it might still be a draw
foreign
what a weird position
I think it's just a draw
must King each three is playing
oh thank you papa oh it's Papa Pizza
chess
is Gary loves pizza still here
I know Papa Pizza chess streams
we have a whole pizza discussion earlier
also I'm in trouble I need to think
about my
decisions here
oh this is big trouble
okay I think I'll go for this and then
F5
I could get like rook and what rook in
three pawns for three minor pieces
I like the prospect of F5 it just looks
more confusing for the opponent
it does allow Queen D5 and King h8
and the king is kind of stuck like you
can't move off the file
that's an E4 but
work
I don't have a G5
let's take the pawn
for a crazy Pawn to take
oh
so I'm down three minor pieces
I have this move
so I have three pawns for Knight and
Bishop but H5 is coming maybe
H5 we can take it though
I have to play this first
okay
pawns are rolling Connect Four
foreign
G3 may be coming
that's a pin
oh no my connect five
oh no my queen oh yes my queen
I was almost standing hey it's another
Rosen trophy hey
okay
oh what a game
that was a crazy game
I mean that was so much more fun than
just repeating three times
I was really disappointed I was looking
forward to connect five I was one move
away
I was also threatening meat in one year
do I even dare look at like the analysis
let's just see I mean I'm sure White's
just winning here yeah
but this position first of all is Knight
G4 or Bishop G4 a good move
Bishop G4 okay that's best approach
oh wow we just played the top Engine
line
so
okay G4 wasn't the strongest but
starting with G4 Bishop G4
and each four takes takes
this is all the top Engine line engine
just says it's a draw
but I played oh I played Queen G5
uh Bishop E3 wasn't right
at five
[Music]
nice graph
okay back to tournaments
thank you to JD Matthews
first time Rhymes up nice
okay
trying to rebuild my streak
oh it's Papa Pizza
[Music]
who I assume paused because they just
sent the read
but thank you Papa Pizza
oh yeah I'll hide the heart rate for now
because my watch is charging
playing rage Hunter
who usually beats me so okay let's try
and
play quickly here
hmm
oh wow did I just trap myself
yeah it's not pleasant already
still may be kind of playable
this is really unpleasant
for this move
doesn't work
wow
[Music]
did I do just deserve this
I think Bishop D5 is coming
if I take
get away with this move
Maybe
and the tactics are flowing for white
the light is kind of stuck
King is kind of stuck
uh
oh that's unfortunate
I have this move though
I can move
okay I resign
oh tough game got outplayed
see kind of starting with um like this
position
once E5 happened
okay back to 2600.
it gets tougher like now I'm gonna be
playing
a lot of title players
I'm gonna open a window it's kind of
getting hot in here
foreign
be right back
okay
window opened
having some fresh air
oh I've I didn't deserve back
that's okay though at least I can um
have some time advantage
really risky line for luck
okay hitting the knights
it's kind of like a good Cambridge
Springs I think
although
see how to deal with this I'm gonna play
C4
hmm
let's play this first
just castling
so I'm allowing takes
ticks takes but not only taken when the
bishop
okay this I forgot was kind of hanging
so I think I have to take 94.
yeah a lot of tactics Happening Here
resulting positions should be okay for
me
and we're trading a lot
foreign
[Music]
take
so take take
to play like A3 or something
oh Rook B3 is a good move
Rook V3 is a really good move
I'm
I only got a lot of trouble here
you have to play like Rook out
one
doesn't even work
I'm just losing I could take it
we have to take it
take
narrow California
good move
might be able to bail out for a draw
hmm
foreign
hmm
[Music]
should not have a lot of that
okay that was a nice gift
I've only just didn't see E4 coming I'll
take it
okay
I probably should have lost that
but Life Goes On
oh goodbye to Southwest thanks for
stopping by
I'm not sure how long I'll be streaming
for it but uh it's 4 23 am for me
uh those are haven't berserked in a
while
playing E4
opponents
it's taking some time
so Queen A5 I played B4 yeah it's a it's
a funny line
it's a gather line
maybe some people have seen my video
covering this
is one of the first instructional chess
videos on my YouTube channel
I showed this line
opponent's clearly not prepared
I can see the bullet reading the
opponent is stronger and slower time
controls
yeah 906 is a good move C6 would have
walked into some funny trap
so now it's kind of like a Danish
where
I'm down upon but I have some nice
Bishops
so it's playable
uh sc5 is an interesting move
wow
I have to be careful here
so B5 I'm thinking that I'll take
and still like B5 I take and then Bishop
D5
hmm
um worst case I take on F6
I think I'm okay playing this first
though
an fc4 I think Bishop C3
uh but then Queen C5 D4
should be okay
foreign
yeah this
this position still has like some nice
Gambit vibes
although
by losing material I have three
if I take
Queen E4 is a good move
I'm gonna have to play F3
I'm gonna be down two pawns and a lot of
time
oh to do
good thing my rook's defended
I'll play Knight G3 next
and blocks winning more material but
only so much I can do here
okay C4 would have won the bishop
because it takes uh Queen D4 check
so I'm I'm fortunate to
only be down the pond
now it's a situation where I think like
both of us want to attack on the same
side
let's start with this move
okay
there's no time to think
uh I'm losing this or this or that
foreign
[Music]
doesn't work
I'm turning this now
foreign
ah good good move while playing
oh what to do
yeah difficult position black played
well that game
um
I'm actually not sure if I had like too
many chances I mean I I miss queen E4 so
click game back to tournaments oh no my
rating
so I'm tied with Papa Pizza who's still
paused
I need one more win to LeapFrog a few
people
playing this person I played many times
before
playing into an English
interesting opening
okay I'm gonna suck
oh no my Rook
I think it's a reasonable exchange sack
okay Knight wants to go here
yeah now it's all about attacking I have
one extra minor piece to attack with
I also have a queen to attack with
White Queen is not helping defend
yeah this actually traps the bishop
um
okay I'm gonna go for style points
it's not necessary but it's that's a
funny line
because if takes I play this
yeah so I went back the queen
Knight of three is also coming
going for the fork okay that was a nice
game
back to 2600.
goth extra tournament points 162 turn
total tournament points
so yeah top 10 I'll have to pass 200.
uh playing this opponent again
if I played earlier
what was the game earlier
oh they fell into that London trap
okay
I'll play a Cambridge Springs
again
385
I played this opening a handful of times
so far this tournament
uh this is a main line
I think castling
at some point the bishop goes back
uh there's some pawns back too like A3
takes takes Queen A3
Magnus Carlson actually played Cambridge
Springs many years ago
he won a nice game with black against
galifond
it was a similar line to
C5
yeah this whole tournament I've gained
like two rating points
it is true I I usually lose like a ton
of reading in this um in these Marathon
tournaments because I berserk so much
but
so far I haven't lost uh any
there's been points where I've been down
but uh
been staying somewhat consistent
yeah I still have this kind of tension
E6
now Bishop just wants to develop
foreign
yeah I think I have to take
I don't want to take but
what to do
I also have to sneeze
I want to sneeze but I can't sneeze
what to do
or maybe we'll trade Queens
okay I'm you
foreign
I think I'm allergic to
staying up so late
or I'm allergic to opening the window
all the allergens coming in
the things chapter blessing me
I do feel blessed now
the interesting move
foreign
it could be a problem
Knight B3 is less scary
so I basically have three attackers and
I'm attacking one of the Defenders
foreign
I could just take
and we'll see what happens takes takes
I mean I think I think this is all okay
unless there's some crazy wow
I have to be careful here because if
takes takes takes his Bishop
or there's a rook B1
but I think I have Bishop C4 there Rook
be at Bish basics
and the bishop defends the Knight
defends upon
wait what am I doing I take your first
if not for Bishop C4 I'd maybe be in
some trouble
but I'm getting two minor pieces
for Rook
and generally minor pieces are like for
choice
but sometimes in the end game The Rook
can be
quite useful
yeah so it looks like
um looks like I'm in trouble because
there's multiple ways of attacking but
after Bishop A6
this weird chain of defense like really
keeps me safe
now it's still a question how to make
progress
like I want to bring the king in
maybe just starting with
actually a little bit stuck
I got five
and they can't easily develop
Ed
yeah here we see the power of the Rook
like it really ties down my pieces
foreign
this move with understanding that F5
will come
and now I'm like my Kings was tied down
to the pawn so I don't know what my plan
is
like let's try down to this Pawn
bishopside Downs of the night
so like I can only wait with my king
unless I want to like sack the a pawn
and get the knight in
just some idea
oh there's almost a really cool idea
like here it takes to here but then A6
okay I have an idea I'm gonna wait till
the king comes to C3 and then I play
this
or I can maybe I put the King on E8
that's interesting
[Music]
oh no my Pawn
oh that's a good move
oh no my position
not sure about this actually
oh no
who's the Stillness
foreign
that's why you never resign
oh wow
what a funny
what a funny finish
I mean white had so white had enough
time too
but it's like a tournament like this
when players are playing for
five hours straight
sometimes this happens
wow
okay back to tournaments
that was a wake up
I'm still awake
I think I I started this tournament
rated 25.98. look how lizard back I've
never beaten this opponent before
we have a dutch
I think I want the castle Queen side
yeah so it's slightly better Bishop
against less happy Bishop
a very positional game though
hmm
all right
taking almost works
not quite
E4 could be interesting
I'm just not sure what the plan is
but the Knight on D3
Are You The Rook should be here
okay
with this I play H6
that way I fix the pawn on each seven
ooh this move
wow
a crazy move
yeah it's still okay though
or is it
well the transformation
[Music]
yeah the plan is to March up the d-pawn
hmm
now this should be pretty
straightforward now
okay
there you go
wasn't easy
how many times have I like crossed 2600
this tournament
I keep going back and forth
oh I have a pretty close score against
this opponent
okay I'll lose
Carol Khan
actually a slav against London
what am I doing did I just trying to
everyone who just did there
Teague is setting in
at least I have something playable
um yep there's about five so probably
this move
wow
I'm very resourceful
hmm
I'm not sure how to handle this
kingy 2 comes to mind
bong cloud
I just needed to defend the bishop
there's nothing else apart from my king
maybe this move
I have to keep this Pawn defended
very strange position here
that's a good move
I think Knight C3 and Rook
D1
scary thing is Bishop F5 but I think I
have enough resources
just a cluster of white pieces trying to
hold on for dear life
maybe four maybe coming
um
I mean should I suck a queen
maybe no need
Queen B1
like we trade a lot I might lose a two
wow
I see three coming
take
hitting the Rook allowing this I take
back
ah nice move
I'm just getting mated wow
well played
yeah
black was very sharp that game I mean
plays a very good game
what to do
okay
on my quest back to 2600.
foreign
Rocky's kicks
um
let's play a black Mustang
okay now we have a gorin
maybe this will be like an album counter
Gadget
or maybe not
this is something though
it's a question how much fun I want to
have like Knight D2 E3
I think I just do this
it's kind of risky but like this
structure is known to be really annoying
to play like even though white has three
Center Pawns
it's possible white will get back upon
it's hard to develop the bishop
some funny ideas to play this move
um
G5 is a little bit over the top
but let's do it
oh I'm going a little bit crazy
[Music]
thank you smudgley
first time Prime
yeah this is the occasional friendly
reminder if you have Amazon Prime
you can subscribe for free super easy
way to support the channel
we do have the prime command
uh yeah you just have to link your
Amazon Prime accounts it's essentially
giving a
free five dollars
in support of the Stream
wait opponent has left the game
I can claim victory in 30 seconds
okay
I will
be ready to claim
I mean I have a worse position I'm down
upon
uh
I did notice my opponent's like internet
connection wasn't great they were at
like maybe half full bars
six more seconds
thank you The Eliminator
clean Victory okay
okay I'll I'll take it I guess
you know that's the first time this
tournament something like that happened
has uh a game much earlier where my
opponent rage quits
but that was a bit different
okay it's orthoop at a time
my first orthostnop of the tournament
so the ortho shop is like one of these
rare lines against a French or I'm
gathering the epon
black accepts it the point of this is to
get like an open position
early pressure against F7
and some very quick initiative and the
Queen's a little bit misplaced here
I've I've actually studied this one
before I know G3 is a move I know if
like if black Chop's a bishop I'm
supposed to take in Bishop D5
so I'm temporarily down two Pawns
oh D2
a down only one Pawn now
I'm wondering about uh
I'm taking in Bishop D5
it looks fascinating
the problem is
text takes Bishop D5
Bishop B7 I take
let's go for it
never played bullet before wow
there's a sound outside the window I
think it's sprinklers
probably sprinklers
Queen D7
yeah let's play Rook D1
I mean I can also play this
wait a minute
Queen G7 good move
foreign
this is uh
opening wow negative six
so showing new here
okay
um I think this is playable
because after it takes I have check
I mean I'm losing a lot of material for
the queen
like a lot of material
so at least I win a queen
oh my Queen's just trapped wow
I Queens is trapped that's that's crazy
well I found that so quickly too
I mean okay I have to
play on a few more moves
it's resignable at this point but
just playing on
as you never know
foreign
yeah I should avoid the trades
actually Bishop C5
that's no good for me
opponent's still taking time though so
it's a bit strange
never resign when you have a rook
and also never resign when you have
funny stalemate traps
I'm playing on because it's it's strange
that Block's taking so much time
and my oppon's never played bullet
before so if I can get to some time
scramble
there is maybe some hope
and we've seen miracles in the past
um play H6
I'd like to spend time on the king move
okay let's go for this
like this is incredible
I'm gonna Queen
it's still completely lost but the fact
that I'm queening
wow
oh is it just forced meat
I have this move
I'm not supposed to have a new Queen
here
uh let's play this
that's so close to force Maids
waiting for this move
which is not gonna happen
uh let's force me yeah
what to do
still never know King is slippery
a very slippery King
okay well played
I should have promoted to a rook
I think that sequence was accurate
wow it's forced meat
yeah there is mismeat into with uh Rook
G2 Queen E5
hey it's Irene what's up Irene
I'm six hours into streaming
Rook G7 inaccurate
hmm
yeah an ap5 was a little bit uh
a little bit too much because there is a
line
um
which actually a lot of players will
walk into after B5 in this position
here the side he actually is okay
because Bishop B7 I can take
although it's still kind of speculative
anyway
um back to tournament
okay that's a tournament
and juggling a few things here
okay we have appearance
nobody's working against someone who's
slightly higher rated than me
and we'll try and we'll try and recover
from the previous game
okay
wow Lee chess is very quick on these
things
um
so just to show and that's one of the
reasons why I played on the previous
game
was uh
yeah so
but kudos to lichas for being very quick
new systems are working well
okay at least we have like a calm game
do I get a rating refund
I do gather rating refunds
other people see this
look at this
I get a rating refund
but I don't know how it works mid game
if I refresh will my reading be higher
uh let's see
no
okay so I have a nice kind of um cube of
pieces
threatening the pawn
probably looking to like bring the Rooks
to the center
foreign
good point is my street get like
refunded
I think it does in some sense
we'll look into it though
um
this is a very team position
we might end up trading everything like
95 trade trade
maybe I'm slightly better because this
bishop has a hard time developing
now C6 should be played at some point
at some point I'm going to need to take
another break
replenish the T
at some point I might just end the
stream too I'm getting kind of tired
but it would be nice to get back to 2600
yeah this is a very uh
we call this I don't want to call it dry
like we both have the bishop pair it
could get spicy at some points
okay this takes doesn't work
yeah Bishop A2 is kind of a threat
I may have misplayed this
oh no I can just defend like Bishop E1
but Bishop C4 I have rookie one
like I want to play King F2
a G3 first
yeah usually when it comes to like an
online with scheme this is a type of end
game where like all three results are
possible
uh time is very important so the fact
that I have more time
is pretty meaningful
um I'll keep the Rook
I just want to play King F2
just get the pieces to slightly happier
squares
yeah the file's wide open
but I'm controlling all the penetration
points
I kind of want to take the pawn
and yeah this position might just seem
that equal but there's still lots of
life like there's lots of ways this
position can transform
despite the fact it's balanced material
relatively balanced Palm structure
now hopefully it doesn't transform badly
for me I think C4 is called for
so we can trade
now one difference is I have a slightly
more active King
it's a good move
Bishop D3
I want to play B4 at some points
some ideas about F5 as well
now F5
hmm
[Music]
F5 doesn't really do much
too
B4 doesn't do much either
some G4 idea
realizing my king is probably better on
C3
but to get there is a bit of a challenge
it's not I should not have a lot of that
move
and we have to trade
yeah the block is slightly better here
because my pawns are fixed on
this Pawn is fixed on light Square
foreign
try something
I was getting kind of spicy
foreign
oh no
I mean it's okay
[Music]
um
oh no
I should have taken the drawer
my proudest moment
oh opponent missed a king mate
how dare they
I shouldn't take him at your house I was
a bad decision on my part Gigi
so how does this reading refund work
back to tournament
so it just shows that I won the game
okay so I guess
that's a bit strange how that works
I guess it makes sense
okay interesting opening
wow does that work
takes takes
that might work
and crazy move
so I'm down the pond listen how am I
proudest opening especially against each
before I move on
but at least uh yeah the position is
still very playable Knight's a little
bit misplaced
I don't really want to trade off the
Knight if I don't have to much rather
restrict the knights
I'm losing another Pawn
um
let's move
maybe it's okay
foreign
good move
take and play B5
how bad is that
fancy
allows me to save the piece
oh no I can't
93
so confused
I was a free piece
wow
a Nature's trout
what a crazy move
um
I'll just have to try and survive
I can't even give it up for anything
Ricky six
I guess rookie two
foreign
okay maybe I have chance oh maybe I
don't have chances
uh smooth
I'm in trouble now
G5
foreign
this
we all know it's coming
and smell it from a mile away
oh no my queen trade oh it's not coming
oh
that's so sad
I had to try it curious my opponent for
not pre-moving
maybe I should have played this
although that would not have worked
either
oh no my stalemate trap
okay
foreign
where like if I lose a game I might end
the Stream
we'll see how this game goes
I'm just working I'm playing
aggressively too
I'm preserving G5
yeah so this is
um I mean G4 is one idea
but no need to rush
thank you Matt now you're asleep oh yes
my sub oh yes
okay Rook G is very typical
yeah this could lead to some grinding
end game like we could trade everything
on G4
[Music]
and we're we're gonna trade everything
I have two sets of double pawns now
but everything's defended
I don't want to draw I I think like
black has winning chances
and the draw offer indicates my opponent
is Maybe
a little bit fearful
and question where the Knight should go
and there's not too many squares on the
board where it can be useful
look at the right moment I want to break
through
uh there's an idea to play Knight F4
it's very committal if I play H4 then
I'm giving up on my plan to play G4
so what I might do is uh
bring the Knight to G6
I'll start with this
okay Simple Plan
uh
yeah we'll play it
I should be careful not to over push
foreign
there's at least a couple ideas to try
there's one funny Checkmate like if the
king lands on G4 and then Knight F6
track meets
I could really use a camel in this
position
another idea
[Music]
which might already has to be careful
okay now the F4 square is weak
it's incredible that like my pawns can't
be attacked
can
I have to be careful
I have to push
what a cool position
before
[Music]
uh it's simple for for light
no white so has to be careful
because the prospect of Knight F4 is is
really interesting
um
quite
foreign
foreign
moves
wait how did how did the game end in the
draw
oh it's probably a repetition
good games
yeah the two ideas were were this and
this
um
like while I was moving around I was
trying to actually figure out if I can
ever sack but it never works
oh it definitely never works my king
can't even get in
um
okay what to do
yeah Knight C4
is 9 C4 still a draw probably not
back to tournament
okay
I've reached the points if I lose a game
I end the Stream
I need sleep soon
so if I keep winning I guess I keep
streaming
um
okay this could be my last game
oh this line again yeah we had this
earlier
um Bishop D3 and E4 this time
I'm hitting the knights
I had a very similar game earlier
very similar where opponent hung their
Queen
um King F1 I guess
I've had Queen D4 check too
still have Queen D4
and call them go for the pawn chain
not sure about the kingpon ending it
should be a draw
there might be chances for me though
Queen side majority
draw
just kidding
I mean queen B1 was a force to draw
there
I guess we're playing on
still offering the queen trade
okay
this is something
it should still be a draw
foreign
everything that I can
not so draw
okay
peaceful finish
and these engines are uh are intense
couple draws in a row still 25th Place
so the stream's not ending as long as I
don't lose
I'll update the stream title too
uh
if I lose a game I end the Stream
okay
let's stop hurting out of time
Stafford gamuta
we've only had like a few staffords this
tournament
someone says play aggressive Gambit
you're getting your wish
the most aggressive of gambits
and we had this exact line earlier my
phone castled and then played King H1
that was a game I mean that was one of
the first games of the stream I won in
like 10 moves
against a different opponent though
oh I'm almost at 30 000 games I forgot
about that
what game number is this
oh 22 more
okay I'll have to have a 21 game win
streak
to get to 30 000
that's asking a lot we'll take it one
game at a time
opponent taking a lot of time here
engine will say like plus two for white
but it's really not that easy to refuse
yeah the idea is very clear so we'll see
how white wants to deal with it
what time does the sun rise also my
watch is charged
I forgot to put a heart rate monitor
back on
E4 Free Pawn
wow
new idea
that's a move
I can take in Bishop B6
that's one way to take out the game
thank you Jordan
the first time sub at tier one
appreciate that
okay heart rate monitor's back on
um
I mean do I go completely bananas
the problem is there's G3
it's a cool move though
I mean it's in the spirit of the Saturn
hopefully the staff organic Gods will
make good things happen
I mean it looks like I'm just losing a
piece after G3 but I do have Queen E5
there's also this move too
but I think Queenie five
oh wait a minute
I messed up
okay I don't think it's huge
mess up but it's not pleasant because
gxtx F4 is coming
I'll take on each three
okay that's good to see
now I'm okay
I think F4 was the last move there glad
your stream exists Autumn marathon
without the competitive anxiety
I'm glad you exist
I'm glad everyone in chat exists right
now
things for tuning in helping keep me
awake
okay I lost a pawn but yeah there's some
interesting compensation
what might end up happening is Bishop D1
Knight C4 B3 Knight B2
or even better uh this move
yeah so I'm throwing this and this
incoming pork
and after King F3 I take
now it's equal material
hmm
I'm spending way too long here just have
to move
the pawns belong on dark squares
except the spot
and this pause
generally like with the Bishops
the pawns should be under experience
so it's four on two on the queen side
but four and two on the king side
and trade
you just gotta start pushing
idea King C5 and B4 coming
foreign
tricky game
I didn't join the marathon right when it
started I joined
um maybe three hours late
started just after 10 my time
how many queens can I make
okay
oh yes all my Queens
games are rating points
27th Place
I'll keep berserking if I lose a game I
end the Stream
I'm playing an I am who is not Biz
drinking back
so this could very well be my last game
uh what's the line here night beef
I think just this
oops
no I was supposed to play Knight P5
or was I
yeah that's not a great opening I don't
think
but maybe it's playable
yeah I don't think I'm reaching my 30
000th game in the Stream
unless a miracle happens
daily so I got some pressure
some nice compensation here
it's a good move though
I mean there's some Greek gift idea
don't think the Greek gift works
I'm trying to set it up but it's not
gonna work unless like we see B6
wow now it might work
I don't see how that defends
and Black's gonna probably sock the
queen but I have plenty of time
I'll have Queen for two mongers
yeah this didn't work in the previous uh
position like I needed my queen to go to
H5 first
because if I played Bishop H7 too early
in Knight G5 there's King G6
but yeah here it works nicely I think
the stream will keep going
okay
that's the question that black resigns
or takes on G5
okay
nice game 17 movement
23rd Place
so that's two in a row
okay I'm not berserking who's this
okay
um
just play chess
I mean now this could actually be my
last game
uh
play time out of
foreign
not exactly Pleasant
I'm just trying to stay alive
oh
okay
kind of this and this
cover the pond
I'm scared of Bishop takes Knight G6
not the most Pleasant
I think Knight F6 first
and unity five
foreign
bring the bishop to F6
wow
I'm in trouble now
there's like one mistake
wow
this is not good
really
it takes
I'm giving up a queen I have two Rooks
for the queen
and something to fight for
objectively it's probably just lost but
still trying to fight
and losing the pawn
um
let's play this
still somehow alive
I need I need to get counter play
against the king
try first
foreign
trick
wow the move
a great move
thank you
[Music]
I can't even set it up
component taking time
okay well that's the end of the stream
what to do
uh tried to set something up there I
mean queen g1's queen D1 the only move
21 was a
oh no everything's winning
Queen G3 even B6 is winning really
ah because I'm just losing E6 and
eventually I'll lose H5 yeah
okay
I hope people enjoyed watching
I'll maybe be back for the end of this
tournament
it's been a long stream yeah it's over
seven hours wow
there's some fun moments
um if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
let me know if you made it this far
again leave a timestamp of your favorite
game
all times to have all the games in the
video description
I'll be using the uh
I'd love to demonstrate here but I'll
I'll leave a link in the description to
the website I'm using the lead chest
timestamper
makes life super super easy
let me make sure I pause the tournament
so another game doesn't start pause
oh no
I was too how do I pause without
rejoining
I have to play one more game
oh no at least maybe we can finish with
a happy note
oh I'm playing one more game
I wanted to end it
no no my
my finale to the Stream
uh the gods have spoken how do I pause
the tournament
I probably have to click pause
okay
not a great position but it's a playable
position that's what matters
no this is final game regardless
unless something like crazy happens
unless the same thing happens but I'm
gonna make sure it's a positive
tournament
I'm accepting
bad Pawn structure
maybe I could have taken there first
I mean I like the prospect of Bishop
Knight Queen Pawn
concerning B4 now
throwing the queen
I think my thread is Bishop E7 it's kind
of a cool move
yeah that was expected
I mean it's really close to like Beauty
I mean Knights
hmm
Page Six
and try this
so the point is if takes I played this
Jason and Bishop F6
I didn't calculate Rook C8 Queen G7
[Music]
King runs
I have Queen H6 in that line
so basically if takes takes takes Bishop
6 Rook C Queen H6
wow
I'm probably in some trouble
or am I if takes I have this wow
once that works
does it really work though
start with the check
and check in Rook C5
hmm
I think everything is
let's start by taking
takes Tech
it's really not so clear
maybe I should start with Queen G7
[Music]
um
I'm not in good shape here
uh we're gonna have to trade Queens
and we'll see what happens
inviting this move
the good thing is that there's no open
files
actually there is one open file
but it takes time to make progress as
black
wow
nice move
I couldn't tell you because
there were issues
yeah I wanted to take doesn't quite work
though
even takes
I have to play the sad move
G5
and the most I can ask for is a Time
scramble
foreign
another good move
okay
there's the pause button actually
clicked that earlier
GG
okay
I think I can end beautifully now right
big things to everyone
a huge thank you to the the person who
made the like amazing donation earlier I
don't know if you're still here but
the anonymous Mouse
um it's been a fun stream
I hope people learned a thing or two
and we're entertained
all of we be back
um before the end of the tournament to
try and
finish strong
so
stay tuned
and okay
I'm back
hey it's Alex Alex Werner welcome back
from NYC
okay so I streamed
yesterday evening
into early this morning
I had a I think a seven hour stream
I'll share some behind the scenes
so
yeah my stream
was seven hours and 20 minutes
and this is gonna be probably four and a
half hour stream
um because that's the amount of time
left in the tournament
for people watching in the future on
YouTube
uh I already streamed seven hours of
this tournament uh link will be in the
description this is uh the finale part
two
and as usual I'll be time stamping every
game
in the video description
[Music]
I can't quite do that on Twitch just
with the nature of live streaming
but I'm rejoining
um barely in the top 300.
185 tournament points
I had some nice streaks and then I I
kind of slowed down towards the end of
the stream uh this morning so try and
rebuild some momentum
quack thank you dinky Daffy
I appreciate the early energy trying to
stay awake
uh we're starting with a nozzle loss
which is this move
um a D5 is already a little bit peculiar
okay
I like the position though easy
development it's kind of like a good
French
because black hasn't played C5
reinforce the bishop don't mind the
trade
I also don't mind just keeping the
bishop on the board
welcome to so many more people
it's nice to be back
hello hello
to jonath ax
so this is Five O Blitz
um I'm trying to climb my way back to
2600 we'll see if that's doable
this is a nice looking move
lights probably coming here
uh G5 is coming
I think what I'll do is
um take and then play G3
but I'll also just go for the attack
I want to take care of it after takes
takes another four
we'll play G3
yeah this is a pretty nice attacking
setup
Queen Bishop battery
um I might have to play this move
although
attacking looks more fun
it's weird like I'm used to attacking on
the king side with the same pattern
foreign
so if I take check
out first
so early calculation exercise
I think taking makes sense Bishop
can come in
the king's unboxing the taken play King
D7 or that move wow oh yes my sub two
years thanks for the countless hours of
instructive and fun content
oh thanks so much Christmas welcome back
happy two years
appreciate that
okay so the Knight wants to maneuver
[Music]
yeah Rook G1 I played Knight T3
this could be a very positional game I
was hoping to just destroy the varking
but
it's not so simple
okay Rooks defend each other
we have the Rook sandwich
yeah this is a weakness so
I like the position
I'll come back to CDR Siri
that's the question how to
grind things down probably this move
first
15 months old Good Times thanks Eric
thanks for the good times
okay this position is a pretty good time
just trying to figure out
like the Knight wants to be
I'm gonna have to do some maneuvering
there's a long maneuver like here here
or there's a short maneuver
to H4
oh H4 is defended
what
okay plan B let's block Hayden
that was a small hallucination but it
should be okay
in the background I guess today is about
Chess there are worse things
yeah there's gonna be a lot more chess
today
about four hours and 20 minutes more of
chess
so I'm up upon here
but
it takes a ton of work
uh C5 is probably coming
I gotta move quicker too
King D3 is fine
like I don't see what my plan is
I have a crazy idea like C5 takes takes
Knight F5 takes
he forking E3
I'm trying to calculate I mean the
thread is clearly this
I mean block is two moves away from
mating
there's also a crazy mate like if here
takes takes takes takes King D4 Rook D2
mates
okay so now I can take on F5 first
I think I'd rather take the d-pawn I'll
have a choice though
but this way I defend F4 I'm winning the
bishop
oh there's a funny mate King E6 hitting
the knights I take with a rook
King takes C4 B5 checkmate
oh there's also a funny mate King C6 oh
no my knight
oh no my knight
someone called an ambulance
oh
oh no my funny mate
oh
there is E4 D5 made in that line I'll
share it after the game
uh
okay let me move more quickly
it still takes a little bit of work
I didn't quite see Force meat there
and this is completely winning now
uh let's push
the E7 is a pretty deadly threat this
Knight has no save moves
okay pawns go marching
Rook D7 will trap the knights
plenty of time
nice game to start the Stream
I'm still a little bit disappointed I
didn't get the funny mate
but I'll just share it on the analysis
board
uh if black were to take the knights
an ambulance would need to be called for
the black king
pretty brutal Checkmate here
thank you Los Marcos
okay also just to share the other line
because I was calculating this this move
and this is another line where I take
here here here then I can actually
choose between B5 made or D5 mates
probably B5 made because I'm that makes
a pawn Samano
okay back to tournament
oh just outside the top 300
but I'm trying to work my way back to
some sort of streak
and the person right above me there has
played a lot of games
oh thanks earlier to Andrew welcome back
gifting to lingley
okay
gotta get my deuce of Stafford
or attempted Stafford
here we have a symmetrical Italian
um
yeah usually what I like to do is make
it asymmetrical like I don't Castle but
I go for just very direct aggression
go for the bishop here too
E4 is a eventual plan
idh5 probably
I can't quite Castle right away because
A7 would hang
but
it's already a nice position
let's
take
each five is the main break
start with C6
restricting the knights
I think I just want to gradually build
up
B6
now Rook A6 might be coming
defending first
and white has a slightly annoying setup
I still want to play H5
oh he's probably looking for ways for
the queen to teleport
wow
I take
hmm
and start by taking
there are too many like nice looking
options there
if I take
longer K7
but the the resulting ending is pretty
nice for black
opponent debating whether to take my
queen it's not so poisonous
but uh yeah the fact that pretty much
everything's defended for me
uh makes a position pretty easy to play
and the strategies to eventually like
coordinate the Rooks
probably invade with this move
so I over defend the pawn want to
mobilize the sky
hmm
and now there's some mating ideas
it's not quite made
it's close though
that's helpful
okay
not a nice scheme
got some berserking points
old Walters says 100th place is 50
points away
which is 10 berserk wins in a row
okay
I'll keep berserking
yeah I'm not using Zen mode because I I
do like to see who I'm playing
it gives me a sense of whether I should
berserk and how like crazy I should make
the openings
maybe at some point I could switch
though
towards the end of the tournament
okay so we have Queen's Gambit declined
exchange variation
um I'll play
I'll play a more aggressive line
H took some Bishop D6
the so-called Casa Corley variation
there's a few traps in this line like if
casting soon then Bishop H2
so normally white will play yeah that's
one move Bishop G3
now we're reaching a position which is
very similar to my game with Magnus
although in the Magnus game I played
Bishop E6 earlier his Knight was on F3
um here I'm going for kind of a cool
maneuver Knight G5 and then
to Target E4
yeah in the early stages of the
tournament like I'm I'm a bit more alert
so
um
especially when I berserk it's so
important to manage my time well
especially in the opening
like I should have probably been moving
quicker
this is still all prepped for me
it's taken me about 30 seconds to get to
this position
I probably had this exact position
before maybe a few times
or at least positions very similar
so I know that taking is an option
like H5 H4 is an idea
I think I'll start by taking in B5
just ensuring that white Cam play D5
it does leave this Pawn a little bit
weak but it also fixes this Pawn on B4
and queen defends upon now
hmm
I want to play G6
hey H5
a very direct move
H4 is interesting so 94
can't really play
yeah 905 comes with Tempo the benefit of
the Knight here is after 95 Queen C7
Knight defends the queen so there's no
tactics
no media tactics
I still want to play G6 in Rosen let's
go let's go
so I'm allowing Bishop G6
which looks scary but after it takes
takes Knight G7
I defend the king I defend the Knight
I think it's okay
thank you Maxima
foreign
like things are stable now
oh thanks so much inactive gamer
says haven't watched in a while
oh maybe you were inactive
thanks for being active again
appreciate the bits
yeah light's been taking a lot of time
so even though I started with two and a
half less minutes
I'm now a little bit up on time
also for everyone just joining I did
stream the like the earlier
um
I started at 10 p.m my time last night
and I streamed for
almost seven and a half hours
so this is the second stream of the
marathon tournament
just over four hours left
I think I'm I'm threatening some cool
stuff like rookie 3 or queen G3 a lot of
fork tactics coming up
I mean 93 is also possible
I like this move though
so I just hit H4 I turned E3
forgot about that
I should have taken on E3
but it's still very difficult position
to play because I'm attacking from like
so many different directions
[Music]
holding on pretty well
okay so pressuring the pawn and trying
to set up tactics again
like if Rook C3
I can take
or take and take
F6
oops
not a great move
yeah not my best conversion
foreign
[Music]
there we go okay
oh I was just trying to like Focus there
towards the end
I was losing the thread a little bit
is this the first time of the stream my
heart rate's passing a hundred
get some workouts
okay
I have to remember to stretch too the
stretching is important
21 months in the 21st century also 21 is
the sum of the first six natural numbers
one plus two plus three plus four plus
five plus six equals twenty one it was
meant to be
feeling 21
happy 21 months old Walter welcome back
thank you menus
foreign
before
most people take on C5
I think my opponent is like aware of the
danger
or not
yeah this is a main trap
like the point of Queen D2 was to set up
the
the situation where this queen is no
longer having really any safe squares
now I usually have this position with
the Rook still here and the pawn still
here
but
yeah it's it's trouble for black now I
can take on F7
hitting the queen and Rook
and life is pretty good
there is a weird line like Queen
the queen g72
it's not so simple actually I'll take
okay box should have taken there
probably
I can move back
yeah now I'm up the exchange and the
pawn
nice opening success
I see the question from Pablo asking
about the the large jono from yesterday
uh yeah they're like I I was pretty
shocking
um
but there was a 2400 dollar
streamlabs don't know which as far as I
can tell it was all legitimate
um
and assuming it is like I'm super
grateful to
uh the anonymous
super super generous support
sometimes I'm a little bit like wary
though because there's been
there's been ways to like kind of use
I don't want to get too into it but uh
like troll with stream mobs in the past
but
uh there's ways to check if uh
things are legitimate
that said it did give me the energy to
go a long ways into this morning happy
birthday harshi's underscore Gambit
hey it's Krishna
thanks for getting merch
yeah this position still takes work
like I'm just kind of playing
patient positional chess
trying to keep a Time Advantage trying
to keep control
over everything and G4 is nice
hmm sip tea
I actually don't have any tea right now
I have water
uh
I have to play this move
I wanted to play this but then there was
Bishop E5
that's the question for black what to do
with the Knight
and now Bishop G3
okay there's a funny okay never mind
assuming the donor was legit
conquaculations have you thought of what
to spend the 2.4 000 on if you wanted
you could either get a really expensive
chess set or get some high-quality duck
chess sets made
yeah I'm just trying to figure out what
to do in this position
uh it's not so simple
uh D group D1
B5
I have to focus for the rest of the game
I'll address questions afterwards
um
because yeah there's some weaknesses and
my pieces aren't so well coordinated
[Music]
um
that's a move
I want to play Rook D1 but
there's this no it doesn't work
[Music]
on this move
I just eventually get to G5
now Rook T1
no draw
hmm
to watch how my Knights and defended
aligned with the bishop
I think I just sacked back hi Eric
hmm
Doc's been fighting really well here
foreign
still
wow Bishop G4
now played
I'm just trying to simplify
I just Blended C2
sub G4 I've
Rook have two
okay I think I'm winning the pawn
a lot of dancing around here
okay finally everything's defended
kind of
I was so close to still meeting that
game oh man
I think when I pre-move queen G3
I think I pre-moved queen G3 in this
position if Vox took back it would have
been still neat
oh man
okay
black fought really well
I mean
it's one of these openings that uh so
many strong players will fall into
as this idea is still not so well known
like this 95 Queen D2 and Knight A4
ah but here it's so it's not actually
like so winning for whites
five wow
how does that work if I take
94.
oh that's insane
so after A3 Queen C5
it's weird the engine give plus one
but then when you let it think it just
says it's close to equal
that's cool counter preparation
[Music]
sometimes that take on G6
E5 Bishop E5
Queen D7 Knight C5
it's insane line
okay this looks better for white
okay
keeping the streak up
welcome back Hari Krishnan thank you
bits not bites
berserking
yeah there's times in these games where
I'd like I have to try and get in the
zone
um
and like every Split Second counted in
that game
would you rather play chess against 24
duck-sized Grand Masters or one grand
master-sized duck
uh
what we get more views
probably the 24 duck size Grand Masters
oh it's Castle
this is um castling is like almost a
novelty this is a preparation I did in
Gibraltar
I'm trying to remember the line though
like take
you take your
so I'm temporarily up upon but it's
likely
the
see it's not so like the back will win
it back so easily
each board is really tempting
queen queen E2
[Music]
trying to get some peace Harmony
like there's 95
so in 97 I take on H7 and Knight G5
wow
at least winning another Pawn here
at most I'm
winning a piece
and then G5 is coming
yeah it looked like vodka was going to
win back a piece but uh
that's not happening
still a little bit tricky
takes
F4
three
the structure is weird
but I think it's okay
wow
take take
I just want to consolidate
so I defend the knights
still kind of a weird position
a little bit low on time
I'm just trying to simplify
but it's not so easy
Queen D3
and G4 I have to watch out for Knight G4
or Knight F4
so I'm preventing Queen G6
now both pawns are targets
Queen E6 expected
yeah once I win this Pawn then
I think it should be pretty simple
how much do you think your level drops
when streaming while playing
that's a very fair question
I don't think there's a huge level drop
if I'm like fully focused in the game
but if I'm like interacting with chat
during the game while having 33 seconds
left then I'm probably more susceptible
to blunders
and sometimes it'll happen like someone
will ask a question or especially when
alerts and TTS come in like critical
moments and
um it has some effect on my play but
it's
it's still manageable
and sometimes it's a matter of like
being disciplined to
like there's cases where I'm not good at
multitasking
here I'm okay like kind of chatting
about something that's not fully related
to the position because
this should be pretty simple to play
pon's also getting low on time
oh yeah there's a question earlier from
emberg I think that was
that was back when I was in like a very
critical moment
maybe I can address it though
something about oh what to spend this
big Dono on yeah it'd be cool to like
reinvest
launch a duck chess piece
um
you have to see what the process is
getting a 3D printer
now there's some funny mates like here
here
okay
okay these games take work
takes a lot of mental energy to try and
play cleanly
um I think overall that was a nice game
though
I'll try and mix up the openings too I
know I've been playing a lot of londons
berserk again
berserking's just trying to like
accelerate my
elevation in the standings
that makes the games like more exciting
too in some cases
yeah there's times like if I really need
to focus and I'll just mute alerts so
it's usually not a big deal
that's more common in like title Tuesday
or like more um more serious prize
events
Bishop D3
Bishop D3 is online
yeah this kind of just goes into an
Italian
maybe Asics first
I should explain King h8 ideas because I
basically want to play F5 at some point
[Music]
I mean my king could have stayed on on
G8
but I guess in this case I've enabled
Knight G8 so F5 is coming soon
foreign
So the plan is pretty simple
this is like a typical
typical strategy for Blitz schemes is to
try and get a position where the plans
are easy
like F5 was simple and now a matter of
doubling
yeah I'd like to make a triple battery
my G5
yeah so now I'm attacking the Knight and
the pawn
I was capturing that G5 but I can just
take it upon
and there's no smothered needs
for this to be smothered mates these
pieces would have to
stop existing
I mean White's gonna try to set it up
six
I'm trying to apply as much pressure as
possible this diagonal
this Fork look at these cluster pieces
this is a thing that matters
okay
staying clean
almost top 200.
uh we can make a prediction later
I think I'll I'll play the whole
tournament but
probably best to hold off now
I'll play E4
yeah probably after I take my first
break
I'll uh
I'll make the prediction myself
at some point yeah I'll maybe enable Zen
mode
maybe once I get back into the the top
hundred
okay this is some line
hmm
allowing Bishop D6
yeah this is going to be a longer grind
like positions like this
box probably already pretty comfortable
but like white is also solid
tree Queens
so I have the bishop Perry so that's one
plus
babak is like super super solid this
Bishop's not so impressive
I'm considering Bishop E3 actually
A4
maybe A4 first
preventing
discouraging B5
Bishop E3
I really don't fully know what to do
here I want to play Bishop D2
C5 takes maybe bishop D2
it's important to play quickly too
and just make gradual improvements
I'm trying to think like long-term
what my plans are
Bishop C1 rookie one
maybe like gradually expand and go for
F5
until I want to trade Bishops
I mean probably F4 now F4 runs into H4
okay I could take the Knight
I'll play F4
I wanna play King F3 G4 H4 is a big
decision for black
so I over defend F4 and I'm preparing G4
and this is progress
like now the bishop can come back
yeah there's potential to exploit the
king
fully open H file
I mean maybe it's still not much
eight is coming
yeah I want to play something like
like that five
the Rooks are probably getting traded
oh wow
it was unexpected
that's probably a good move though
I think I'll take
now the benefit of two Bishops against
Bishop nine is I basically control
when to play Bishop takes Knight like
it's very hard for black to avoid the
trade
and it's very hard for lock to like
force trades
so essentially I can trade on my own
terms
I'm threatening to play this and win a
pawn
which I think blocked just allowed
I mean Knight B6 I play B3
that defending both
Ponder smiling at the fact that it's not
so simple though
I see five
hmm
and it's really not so simple
[Music]
five
yeah this might just be equal
I might just take a draw
a block doesn't want to draw
that's interesting
I've been a little bit slow this game
foreign
it's going to be 50 move rule eventually
yeah
okay
had plenty of time there
um
yeah I thought I was winning a pawn
but I didn't want to go for this line
Bishop B7 Knight C5
let's see
engine says I should go for it
but it's it's close to equal
[Music]
I thought there was some risk here
like Bishop uh C6 takes
because this Pawn's a bit weak this
Pawn's so well defended
okay
still haven't lost a game this stream
but there goes my winning streak
unfortunately
okay
I'm 11 games away from thirty thousand
so at some point I will be playing my 30
thousandth game
this stream
opponent didn't move
free reading
uh
okay
Act of tournaments
I think that's my first game winning in
Zero moves
I'm almost back to 2600
it's a risk but
I'm trying to get some momentum it's
been working out so far
yeah my highest Blitz rating on Lee
chess
uh people can check I don't think I've
ever crossed 2700.
somewhere in the high 2600s
a slightly weird Pawn structure
I don't think the pawns are too weak
let's defends both
like there's still potential for G4
but it takes work
the you Paul Morpheus happy two months
yeah light's probably not better here
unfortunately
[Music]
um
I repeat one first
and there's ways to make it
like sharper like eventually go for G4
we might might see this maneuver like
Knight B8 to C6
hey it's John thank you John
shout out to John
if you're just joining it's been a long
streaming day which started yesterday
evening
this is my second stream of the marathon
tournament
um
I'm only about an hour into this stream
but I did stream seven hours last night
through early this morning whoa It's
Anna Maya
I uh I read it Anna Maya
much earlier this morning appreciate the
rain
shout out to John and Anna
okay let me try and not flag here
appreciate the energy
so yeah everyone's just joining it's all
the marathon
it's a tournament that's open to
everyone I think there's there's well
over like 15 000 players I assume
anyone can join
okay I like the fact that I no longer
have double D Pawns
okay restricting the knights going for
this move
whoa It's Anna kramling where are all
these raids coming from thank you Hannah
that's a triple raid in the span of a
minute it was John Bartholomew Anna Maya
and Anna crowling
thanks so much
that's a big breakup
thank you
gifting to Anna
so again do I have to repeat myself
again for people just joining
it saw the marathon this is a 24-hour
long tournament
um total I played about eight hours
maybe eight and a half hours
um where are my tactics
okay let me just try and confuse the
opponent
both Brooks are having staring contests
in the distance
this move is primarily played to dream
my opponent's time
it's kind of confusing
okay we just trade
oh
okay now it's kind of scary like Rook C3
coming
be really careful
oh I wasn't really careful
wait how does this work
I have Knight F2 just got an ad and we
cannot have that
I'm holding on to the night but it's
still a terrifying position
there's some potential Queen drain
not seeing it
I was trying to calculate
a C3 is now hanging
oh it's too slow
way too slow there
oh good game though
yeah for some reason I was expecting uh
I was expecting uh Queen C2
but yeah the queen was annoying and even
here it's so hard to pre-move
okay what to do that's my first loss of
the tournament or of uh not the
tournament of the Stream
okay
um it's time to tilt a little bit
I'm gonna play the egg
for those unaware of the egg e g g
it's actually not a terrible opening
against Knight F3
has some nimzo Indian vibes
foreign
okay I guess I'm just moving Pawns
this is my life now I'm just moving
Pawns
developing pieces will come in the
middle game but
the US Terry welcome back
yeah develop your pawns before your
pieces always bring out your queen early
always play the egg good source of
protein
thank you to the subs
so I'm still like very underdeveloped
it's really not a bad position though
this bishop wants to feed Keto
if ever a D5 I play E5
yeah this probably isn't like the most
child friendly game
or like beginner friendly game like I'm
breaking all the principles this game
like 90 of my moves have been Bond moves
maybe 80 percent
F4 might be coming
I'll play Queen H6 how about
always move the queen multiple times
how many principles have I broken
it's time to like play a normal move
okay now we're getting a really closed
position
in closed positions the fact that you're
underdeveloped
um doesn't always mean so much
wow
okay White's just trying to punish me
but I think that was just a free Pawn
yeah there's a lot of like open squares
around the king
but it's really hard for a way to
exploit the king
controlling the only open file
defending the pawn
the main thing that scares me is this
bishop
like if the Rook somehow gets in
okay
hey it's Ben what's up Ben
you still need to make the egg
compilation yeah Ben's been like
clipping every moment
there's a mention of egg
good to see you
I did play the egg earlier in this
tournament
and I had like such a terrible position
but I won the game so
and so far it's been a successful
opening for me
um
ignite I mean this night's ready to come
in so
yeah probably have to take
maybe not though
allowing this
I think you're trying to learn
good to see you
if I take those takes I have to be very
careful
and queen each Southern
over defending
because I want to try and win the pawn
hmm
I don't know my planets
they're just move
maybe like this idea
never mind I need to keep the pawn
defended
What's Happening Here
okay new plan King G6
it might be three
okay the idea is Rook H1
such a confusing position
[Music]
maybe now I take
let's move back
still holding on
and there's takes takes
so it takes takes takes takes takes
takes
not happening
now I just want to take
[Music]
wow what a move
that's a great move
I'm just losing
I missed that move
well played
yeah
ah Bishop E8
very nicely played
oh no my king
I'm not even too upset nice attic
I was blind to the threat
oh no my egg
to do
okay no time for Raging or quitting
I'm still trying to break into the top
200
. the top 100 are gonna is gonna be
not easy
berserking continues a little bit
foreign
first
I'd like to play more aggressive this
game but
also have to just do what the position
calls for
and take some 95
and this first
foreign
okay so there's there's a few attacking
resources like Queen H3 Knight G5 F5
C4 Bishop C3
and queen H3 is more most likely to
start with also Knight E5
in combination with F5
yeah these are the most likely arrows to
be played out
also Bishop H6
I mean sometimes when you're attacking
you just have to like spot what the
most
effective like punches can be
punches threats
F6 likely
so defending
hmm
getting the pawn
it could get weird if black does take
here
like it should be okay
so now after takes takes the pawn is um
is kind of loose
okay I don't know how Bach defends King
F7
A5 wow
okay
some progress
so Knights versus Bishops but I have a
really nice word for the night
yeah that was a nice trade for me
the night is um
basically Untouchable here
it's my dear Rook E6
I think rookie 6 Rook C6
um
oops
a small mistake
I just lost a pawn black didn't take it
okay
it feels like progress is being made
starting this now
these pawns are weak
have to watch out for this
10 months streak happy 17.
just be really careful here
that's another time scramble
Rose and baby time
thanks to all the returning Subs
oh no okay this is fine
foreign
just too slow
too slow what to do
I miss mates
um
is close
I missed Knight H5 and then take on G7
good game though yeah lock survived a
long time there
uh okay all berserk back
readings taking a small dip
lots of nature
man breaking into the top 200 is not
easy
but now it's time for Canada time so
okay
oh we'll have a fun line
that's a nice way to rebound from a
tragic loss
okay 11 moves Sapphire Gambit win
that's the great thing about Saturn like
Bishop C4 looks natural but it's pretty
much already losing after Knight G4
okay
203
need one more win
yeah let's get some momentum
never lost to this opponent
maybe another staffer Gambit incoming
staff are gathered part two
or part 1000 something something
have I reached my Thirty thousandth game
yet
I'm probably getting close
wait let me check is this it
oh five more games Okay thank you Pablo
so this is like the true magical line H4
discovered by vampire chicken
I am losing a piece but there are some
funny mines
in Queen H4 here
yeah so compared to the previous game
this is a
more advanced
trappy line of Stafford
it relies on some like deep engine Leela
analysis
where I'm I'm currently down two minor
pieces
but the pieces I do have are like really
well placed
there's a crazy line
procure I take take okay never mind
I mean I could win the queen
I think it's time to
cash in some of the material
and now the bishop is pinned
out of The Bishop's hanging
so I went from being down two minor
pieces to now having a queen
Queen and pawn for rook and Knight
but Alex position is in
in some distress
hey my heart rate fell below 60. this is
how I find my intercom
just a nice
calm staffer Gadget
uh
uh
so I'm threading made in one
night's pinned
King here it's made in one
checkmates
nice little mate
the queen rook and Bishop all player
role
okay
that was that that was a field good game
Stafford Gambit wins are one way to get
out of tilt
so finally top 200.
back on the streak
if I might not see him I'm gonna play E3
and try and transpose into a Saturn
pre-moving E4
we will have like a Stafford or England
or walrus
okay we have reverse walrus if E5 we
transpose into Saturn
yeah this is a slightly questionable
opening
the last few games were so nice though
that
[Music]
um
I just can't get enough staffer
thank you chunky crumper
so I'm down the pond but I have two
Center files
black has two Center Pawns
we might see casting green sun
and Bishop probably wants to go back
something like this
before
foreign
of night maneuvers
F4 may be coming
four Bishop C1 Knight D4
Queen D3
C5 might be coming
hmm
I'm in a little bit of trouble here
this bishop is strong
some Greek gift
doesn't work
thank you
I mean A5 is probably coming
I have F4
let's start with this
good move
uh what to do
losing C3
of Rook C3 I take on d8 it's kind of
interesting
[Music]
foreign
black takes that I win because back rank
mates
like I think it's okay to trade Queens
here
all right I didn't have time to
calculate
it's still maybe an issue
I willingly went into a King Pawn ending
down upon
if I have a clear path
so key six King F4 and then E3 is an
important move A6 A4
it's still losing
foreign
I was hoping for uh Queen F3 and then
King H4 with the the stalemate trap
didn't quite work though
not so nice
that's a tournament
yeah uh I went a little bit overboard
with uh the opening there
oh no my top 200 standing
yeah I have to be careful with uh
berserking
and playing dubious openings
oh this is a player who I won the
Stafford earlier
right
yeah that was a really nice game
so very usually oh no my knight
if they're usually an E4 player they
probably don't encounter the England
but they avoided the the Trap
so H3 all the H5 I am being hyper
aggressive here
just trying to like get the quick
meeting attack
no mercy
okay 12 move win it's a pretty good
recovery
opponent didn't fall for the first trap
it fell for the second trap
or just kind of walked into a trap
so we're almost at game number 30 000.
refresh
two nine nine nine seven
four seconds
oh this is two nine nine nine eight
that's orthostnop Gambit time
calculating Queen D5 visual C4 Queen G2
take on F7
that line is insane but it's just
simpler to take a pawn and win The Rock
uh
that's a problem sometimes when
calculating a common Pitfall to like be
focused on one move and forget to
consider the other options
I mean queen c8's also a move but
yeah this is pretty straightforward
I did allow Queen G2 for a moment there
and now everything should be okay
yeah what opening should I play for my
37 000th game
London Stafford depends what color I am
95 is coming
there's some compensation here for luck
cabbage
foreign
the bad egg the headache the cabbage
head
the beach cafe
I haven't played the bead opening
it's only choices
oops
I just lost something
the good thing about being upper Rook is
that when you blunder The Exchange
you're still a material
so I'll still be at the a minor piece
opponent's fighting though
not giving up
and Bishop is pinned
I like to play the ah opening
or I could just play the haha
which is like a over enthusiastic crab
I should move quicker
King Safety First
like I'm not too scared here
which actually makes me kind of scary
because when I'm not too scared then I
usually get careless and that's a scary
thought
okay plan of this and this
maybe this
or this
too many plans
I should play Bishop E5 at some point
also rookie one
oops
forgot about that move
okay maybe Rook lifting
it's close
E5
okay I think things are under control
here
and queen's overworked
okay okay
uh refresh
it's coming two more games
okay I'll position this game
we have a Grand Prix attack here
uh wait why did I play D4
D4 is not the not what I'm supposed to
do
muscle memory took over
yeah this is game number 20 999.
[Music]
wait no
I can't I can't even say numbers 29 999.
it's a big number it's hard to say
correctly
but what should I do I'm so conflicted
everyone in child is giving their own
unique opinions
I need to come up with some game plan
okay five
this is looking nice
yeah there's certain openings that are
like you really need cooperation for the
or with opponent
Bond cloud is something you can play
regardless
probably not the wisest
um
how to do this
gonna be okay I'll just prevent B4
a lot of people saying London is white
which I'm not against
I'll keep it uh within my bread and
butter territory
wow
foreign
okay simple tactics
okay here we go
it's time for the 30s thousandth game
oh I'm black oh my Point's berserking
uh refresh just to show
look at this two nine nine nine nine
refresh and
King's gathered
okay I'm playing Falk pure counter
gadgets
also twitch chat says hi to YouTube
[Music]
hi YouTube I'll have to make a clip out
of this
um I don't know my prep here maybe this
move
I I don't know the theory here
but there's a funny line Queen B5 Knight
D7 takes Rook p8s
like we're both trying to be ultra
aggressive
like white played the king's United I'm
counter-gameting
not lights going on some adventure with
a queen
already a fun game so far
where's the queen going
congratulations on 30k oh thanks so much
Singapore backgammon
oh look at this queen C6 Bishop D7
oh no White's Queen
if Queen B4 Knight D3
oh yes okay so I got a winning position
in 10 moves
are less than 10 moves
that's a good start
now let me try and convert
maybe with some more funny lines
yeah the knights want to do damage like
Knight B4 is a
pretty big threat
there's two ways to defend the pawn
wow
where's my smother meet
so E3 is coming
there's a really funny line
I can't resist
it just looks too much fun like takes
takes
I'm gonna have a Pawn on D3
it's slightly irresponsible
but also really fun
I guess E3 is coming
okay let's develop the bishop maybe this
move first
yeah this is one Pawn prevents this this
and this from ever like getting into the
game
don't mess with my giggle Pawns
oh
okay why he's trying to mess with my
gigapons
uh I could take
oh there's my T2
I need C2 Bishop B4
I'm going for this
I'm trying to calculate the line where I
sacked the The Rook
I don't see how it works though so let's
just Castle
or do I preserve castling for later
maybe Queen d8
no let's take for no I don't know what
to do
it's taken Queen d8
this kind of backfired
okay never too late to Castle
oops my night's just trapped
my name was trapped
uh don't hurt me
let's make a queen
this queen wants company
[Music]
good move
I'm in trouble hi Eric
hi
oh no
no
oh no my 30 000th game
oh I got a little bit too fancy there
oh I'm so sad
I thought everything was gonna be
winning
this will still go on YouTube that's
kind of a sad finish though also
Whitehead made in one here
did White have
there could have been some potential on
the song needs
so what to do
oh I was calculating some I wanted to
play Queen E4 and then Saturday I just
couldn't find the mate
and like yeah I think G3 wasn't
necessary
okay fun game though
that was a learning experience
so I wonder how long it'll take to get
to 40 000 games
stay tuned for the next video
okay playing Mr assassin
let's rage I'm so enraged right now
England Gambit declined
oh yeah I'll try again in 10 000 more
games
um
They're all playing the G4 idea 95.
yeah this is very Budapest Gambit like
because this might be a direct
transposition
even though this came from an England
Gambit declined
so the idea is to lift The Rook
as a very typical idea in this opening
it's pretty rare that the whole
rank is just opened for the Rook
oh no my Pawn
it's a good move
and G5 may be coming
I think you chicken Parma
yeah it looks weird to go all the way
back
but that way the Queen's not a Target
now there's some idea of G5 and Rook H3
and there's these ideas like the bishop
wants to
experience life
I'm also realizing like D6 hits the pawn
so maybe I'll keep options open for the
bishop
and at the right moment like G5 could be
nice
opponent taking time we've played once
before
I don't remember that game
okay simple attack
I'm thinking about lifting another Rook
lift Rooks got swollen
dinky Daffy back with a quack
I take
taking doesn't work though because fe5
I mean
let's go for this
I'm threatening some crazy like take and
Sack and
attacks I won't be with you
and then snack
yeah the Rooks want to snack on some
Pawns
I'm not gonna calculate
I didn't even realize the night was
hanging too
um
I assume this is
where's my mate
I'm looking for the mates
it seems like it should be simple but
not fully spotting it
wow King E4
and then G6 mate
King G2 Queen okay so it's it's force
made in every line
um
there was some more beautiful mates
there
I couldn't find the main after King H2
though
it's made in three
I'm too tired for this what's the meat
oh Bishop G4 oh that's simple
ah can you shoot Rook H3 in other lines
but in this line I mean what happened to
game
if King E4 looking to run this way
Bishop F5
is made into its double check
there's three illegal moves
or no there's two legal moves just this
and this
if this G6 checkmate
and if this bishop E4 checkmates
okay that was a pleasant game
that was thirty thousand and one
I should go back and find my very first
game on leechas
but I definitely didn't stream it
have to scroll way back in my game
history
okay I'm playing a four this this is
actually three nights
I would have played the Halloween if
opponent allowed it
foreign
to keep pressure on the clock
this is pretty simple position to play
too
preventing Knight C4
so two and a half hours left
feeling good staying hydrated I had
coffee earlier so
helped to have some caffeine boost
now Block's playing well here
just a little bit slowly
I'm getting forked
I'm losing a piece
losing a piece
oops
okay I have to fight back now
not the end of the world I have two
pawns for it
we could trade Queens
but not yet
hmm
I assume black is going for a win
G3
oh
not pleasant
it's still holding on
foreign
foreign
yesterday I won my first game with the
Stafford nice
let's go
okay survived that one that was close
that was really close
oh emberg found my first game
oh you searched by date oh nice
uh I'll take a look later so another
game just started
things on Burger
yeah using the search function is
probably more effective than just
scrolling down
from the most recent games
hey it's Joe what's up Joe
I just realized I have not taken the
breakouts
should probably take a break at some
point
yeah this is a nice formation
um
because this bishop can't really enter
the game so easily
and this is going to be a long lasting
pin and queen D3 best move
[Music]
so there's a few attacking ideas
I think I'll go for Knight H5
I'm definitely not casting Queen sign
I mean for now I think it's okay to
leave the king in the center
and eventually like another four
let's start with Rook d8
I'm trying to hold things together
very soon I might take five allows
wow
well it's not even a sack
I'm in some trouble here
okay I think casting kind of saves me
this almost works but then Rook D1 the
same thing Rick do you want to take with
Chuck
meanwhile time is getting a bit more
level
oh there's a question what is the
staffer Gambit
uh yeah it's a fun opening that uh
I've I've been enjoying playing
it's supposedly named after Mr Gambit
wow 95.
can't take
can't take either way to play this move
I mean why could take
and queen C6 is probably coming
or not
Queen C6 would have been nice to set up
the fork
now I'm hitting the rook and the pawn
and I started with Queen on F3 and then
on F4
it'll be a lot of Amazing Ideas
hey thank you Anonymous gifting to chess
face India
oh that's a good question so there's a
question
what percentage of my games are Stafford
candidates
and I think the math is pretty easy
uh because I've played
okay now just over 30 000 games
um you know this just wins a queen
I played I think somewhere in the range
of like a thousand uh like maybe a
thousand fifty suffer gambits
so essentially one in 30 games
yeah there's a few fight checks
my Rook beam one will come
ooh
okay
go for this
can I get a pawn mate
okay
there we go
thank you to sphincty Mickey
walks into a bar and orders 10 beers the
bar man then asks him how he would
prefer to pay for all of that the duck
then says just put it on my bill smile
oh nice
black just resigned what
okay I don't get those working points
for that the game was too short
top 150. let's go playing La diva
uh let's go for this
hmm
yeah so I'm defending
they can come in
very close position
that's the question what the longer term
Maneuvers are
just I just hung upon
oops
I was thinking my knight should be on F5
like not the queen
so bad for me
I don't think oh it's
7.51 Stafford Gambit accepted lines as
black only chess with a win percentage
of 74 well not bad
I assume those are my stats
thanks for sharing that
okay I'm winning back upon
the scary pun to take is now that each
file is open
but we're going into some end game
I think F5 was just a hallucination from
lights white assume that g-pawn's pin so
The Bishop's not defended but it's a
rook that's pinning the g-pong
okay now this is actually a threat so
but my own ideas like I can take
hitting multiple things
yeah Rook A3 will be pretty strong
okay
top 140.
on the win streak
well that's five in a row
what should I do
I'll berserk back
okay I'm playing this funny gavit line
this is like a new trendy Gambit that
has been played the top levels recently
I've been playing a decent amount in my
own games
um
Knight C6
yeah there's some idea like
this bishop here and here it prevents G3
because on F5
traps a knight
and I'm still threatening a five
foreign
was a funny threat
foreign
Knight H2
now I just want to checkmate
very fun position to play
another three probably coming
Bishop F3
yeah White's probably about to kind of
escape the danger
and there's still pressure though
the rookie seven Rook be8
okay I have the Queen Bishop battery
still hard to break through
a lot of kind of dancing around here
but the pressure's still on
should probably take at some point
I mean
then let's first
I'm down two pawns but it might not
matter because
I mean some funny threats
White's also kind of stuck like this is
a
Rook C4 is a good move
I have this move
and queen C6
it's a funny line
King G4 Queen G2
the king cannot come back
I'm down a bishop here but this King is
in the wild
okay preparing some pawn moves
the king now has no legal moves
almost had opposition
okay that was a pleasant game welcome
back to IRB thank you Magic Pro
appreciate the first time Prime
[Music]
so it's time to make a prediction
there are
what two hours left of the tournament
[Music]
just over two hours left
so
how will Eric finish in Marathon
what place how about
um 1 through 30.
31 through
50.
51 through 80.
81 through 100.
100 to 1000.
100 plus how about
I'm not yet in the top hundred what
place am I in actually
usually 100 plus is fine
okay here's a prediction
I hope these make sense
we'll do um
20 minute prediction
and now I will disable emote only mode
[Music]
okay
back to tournament
uh yeah I'm disabling pentatonic
maybe I'll enable Zen mode though
Zen mode
oh I can't I'm I was trying to press Z
preferences
Zen mode
okay
okay Zen mode enabled
so for those unaware Zen mode hides
the reading and name of my opponents I
have no idea who I'm playing
I just know oh
oh we have Yasser too and we have Bishop
four this is this is horrifying this is
horrifying it's a knight C6
um and
we have Yasser pentatonic and zendo all
in one
okay that that's moving Bishop B5 is The
Right Move we look to C8 Knight takes C6
and then I was gonna go
pass
C4
hey man I'm gonna murder the bum
wait do what what did Yasser say
um
Queen B3
so let me put the queen on E7 you get to
win the pawn back
Knight F3
very natural moving this is a little bit
overwhelming I agree
sweet I'll turn it off after this game
that's tough
Bishop H5
it's all about the initiative
true
Queen C2
Bishop B6 well we'll certainly keep a
very close eye on that game Bishop back
to G3
private King G2
I'm threatening to trap the Knight Queen
F6
lovely Queen E2
Queen G6 and also
and is this an issue if black plays H4
no it makes a lot of sense this is a big
issue for black uh it's all scary uh
and let's go with the flow big big win
here in the in this August 2100
2400 wow okay
that's the tournaments so I I was using
a Chrome extension it's called demit me
chess
where you can have different
commentators very Dynamic play by black
but I'm disabling it for now also
disabling pentatonic
okay back to normal still keeping Zen
mode though
jerk
going for the G Pawn push
it's actually nice to detach myself from
who I'm playing and just trying
to play the best chest possible
um so G5 is a move
I mean Knights
C6 hmm
Rook H4
I want to play this move
it's risky
if I'm just going into box crib
thank you Andrew gifting to walprus
welcome back to Irene
uh this is a big issue
I mean I have a five
five is maybe okay
but yeah White's a little bit worse here
ah what to do
I'm sacking upon
I was probably losing the pawn anyway
but
the plan is to get the Knight to E3
and then Rook to D7
at least there's some activity here
I can take this
Rook wants to reactivate
for
[Music]
um
there's a crazy line
how do I make it work
I'm 20 seconds left
yeah so this is idea to play G6 in
checkmate
black isn't a pickle
that's a move
oh no
foreign
I tried to make it happen
I wonder who I'm playing
uh someone rated like 2600 right
25 57 oh I put Posse yeah papasi knows
me well
I've had one stalemate trap against
papasi before
okay good game
mode
okay
okay Full Tilt England gather time
interesting
being aggressive here
I think this is already like good for
vac
um
why did the point resign though
what you resigned but why
because if I take those takes
I guess I wouldn't exchange though
is it really that bad for whites
white has a pawn for it
yeah well you're resigned in like um
in a better position
wait upon was cheating
oh opponent got flagged wow
boy was playing like an engine really
okay wow leech has very quick I would
not have guessed like it seemed like
white was just allowing some counter
play but
I guess that was all
like strong engine verified moves
it happened a few times the previous
stream
[Music]
um
yeah there were a couple games last
night where my points were
like playing
nearly perfectly and then subsequently
got banned
um
but leeches has been on top of it like
kudos to reach us
being very prompt
okay this is already a nice line
yeah I think after Bishop H4 I played G5
and then try and win the E4 Pawn
like this is a better version of the
scotch because I haven't played Knight
C6 yet
so I was very quick to get the Rook to
the file
my D5 might be coming
play this move
and try and join upon Queen D3 is
expected
looking at um takes and then okay Queen
takes I win the pawn
on this line I'm also maybe winning a
pawn
um takes takes
it's okay actually
like I have nothing developed
um but this is an important move King f8
ensuring that I'm not getting muted
and
I'm gonna follow the opening principles
in the end game
develop my pieces
so Knight B5 I have this move
[Music]
um
what's the best way to do this I think
take some Bishop by five
it simplifies things a bit like takes
here like back
wow
uh
yeah this isn't so simple
I think it's my benefit to trade Brooks
get a
scenario Bishop verse Knight
my king is more active here
A6
oh look at this so Knight A3 Bishop D3
Knight's trapped
F3 is a move f3b5 king of two
I don't even need to play Bishop D3
we'll just start with B5
so plan is this this
probably need to include this
if I can win the pond I should win the
pawn
I'm not chopping the night
you should have enough time to convert
here
foreign
it's actually not so simple though
like I'm gonna have to do some
maneuvering also just allow D5
maybe isn't so bad
yeah so now the King has a clear path to
C5
I think D5 was actually a positional
mistake
I mean my Bishop is kind of stuck
like G4 my Bishop's essentially trapped
but it can never be one
the King has to always keep an eye on
this Pawn
and the knight's also restricted
like the bishop and Knight restrict each
other
Knight's also restricted Now by this
Pawn by this Pawn by the king
D1 not an attractive Square
Yeah the more I'm looking at this the
more I'm realizing it should be pretty
simple
but you never know
C4
I just want to make sure I keep the
outside past Avon
yeah there is a difference between being
trapped and being stuck trapped usually
implies that like you're gonna lose a
piece
being stuck just means a piece can't
move
oh that's a move
and go after the Deep pond
I should defend first
um
this is this is a Time Scramble now
like now the night's stuck
gambits forever
okay I'll get it the next game just for
you
what am I doing
okay I'll guess like 2400
2305
okay
118
. it's gonna be a struggle to break the
top 100.
um
most people think I'll finish 51 through
80.
yeah we got under two hours left
oh
I thought I would play a Gambit
okay I'll gather my H Pawn have
uh or I'll get a naive
okay I'm playing a Joe Bravo London type
gamut my heart rate monitor uh got
disconnected
either that or I have a very steady
heartbeat
yeah this is a dubious line
it's interesting though
I'm black extending
I don't know where my king should go
before first
foreign
[Music]
maybe bishop D5
[Music]
been meaning to get one of these for the
gym oh they can't wait to wear it while
I train to be one of the best swimmers
in California flexed bicep flexed bicep
flexed bicep keep flexing
or a murta
getting a tank top I assume
I appreciate that
okay so I'm preventing black from
playing D5
I'm also kind of trapping the Knight
like this is already a threat
although there's Queen
I'm safer to Castle first
I wasn't sure about E3 ideas
okay Rook here
Rook P1
thank you
very confusing position like all the
pieces are awkward
hmm
I think I trapped the knights
I'm still trying to figure out some
trickiness
at least I went back some Pawns
[Music]
Go Eric go
thank you McNuggets
I'm concerned my pieces are out of play
let's play here
I mean Knight G3 Bishop F2
I'm still down the pawn
down two Pawns
what's my knight doing
okay
Knight C8 is Knight C8 in the chat shout
out to Knight C8
one of the mods on this channel oh no
my knight
actually maybe it's still okay
I'm just not winning anything
I want to play this oh I'm losing stuff
that's not good
okay trying to create confusing
confusion here
in kind of a triple Fork
my Knight's still trapped
minor piece end game
foreign
hey it's a fork get forked
I got still need it
that's why you never resign kids
and adults
I mean what's my opponent's rating like
one twenty three hundred
oh 24 36.
let's go
okay
it goes on
I'll take it
I'm still trying to work my way up
I got some silly emotes in chat
staffer Gabba time
almost Mal slipped F5
okay we have a Goring Gambit
yeah this is a slightly
um more timid variation
but actually playable for white yeah
there's compensation for the pawn
so I'm upon here White's gonna get the
bishop pair most likely
throw in the check
hmm
and this move
it's a risky move but I think I'm just
in time
I'm avoiding this avoiding this
threatening this now
I broke the PIN
and now I have the square for the king
making sure I'm not pinned
hmm
I still have some issues to solve
and this is so passive
like curling up into a small ball
but trades probably benefit me as long
as I can hold on to my extra Pawn
yeah this Pawn's well defended
this Rook is going to be a pain to get
out
foreign
if I missed a fork there is one point
where 94 was illegal because I was
pinned
[Music]
I just want some sense of activity
group here Bishop here
White's taking a lot of time so I'm
probably playing someone
like a few hundred points low rated just
given the time management
take
like still how do I develop though
at this move
foreign
about a minute
okay now my D6 can come
not the most Pleasant position to play
but it's
and sometimes
a position where you got to do what you
got to do to just hold on
it's not like the flashy attacking chest
it's more just surviving and
holding on to the extra material
trying to win the later stages of the
end game
like be
E6 reinforcing
and finally The Rook can make its first
move of the game hopefully
consuming I can play this
there's kind of a cool threat to play G5
Bishop G5 and then Bishop B3
we trade
lose upon
maybe this move
[Music]
um
this move
realizing the square is a nice
nicely controlled
and in White's territory
and Bishop B5 doesn't hurt me
and yeah we're gonna go for good luck
trades thank you you Trevi
oh
yeah The Bishop's pinned
so I'm still up upon
time is leveling out
yeah now it's a matter of end game
technique
and playing quickly
make use of the three on two
almost forces a trade
goal is to get to C5
I'm guessing 20 2300
[Music]
23 41 okay
a nice game
held on there
so 90 minutes left
it could be a challenge to break into
the top hundred
especially like five in the games they
take a while so
um yeah we'll see how many more games I
get to play
but I'm going to try and like be
aggressive trying to win quickly
berserking
I think berserking just uh like
generally a good decision if I wanna
elevate my tournament standing
hmm
B6
um play A5
I wasn't quite sure how to handle that
threatening this now maybe
okay so takes takes takes takes takes
Knight F2
sadly my night gets trapped in that line
so
I'm allowing this but then Queen G5
hmm
okay at least it's stable now
idea B5 B4
I think I'll just go all in on the queen
side Knight C4
B5 coming soon
I mean light could force a queen chain
although it's not for us I could play
Queen C5
now I'm threatening Knight A3
along with B4 ideas
realizing Queen C7 B4 Knight A4
I can't take like a mated
Queen f8
this first
gonna be helpful to know my phone's
reading here
okay I'm not taking a draw though
I'm playing for a win
C5 idea
d8
okay I'm going absolutely crazy here
I just sat tonight
wow really
opponent just forgot
throw out something
okay
uh 2400.
22.87
okay that worked out nicely
yeah I mean like 92 the game could go
like keep going but
I'll take that
on the streak
so if I get to 300 tournament points
that's well in the top hundred but still
kind of far away
um
interesting opening
I think already it's pretty Pleasant for
light
like G4
[Music]
E4 doesn't quite work though we'll just
develop normally
the d-pawn gives me a sight space
advantage
which bodes well because all the minor
pieces are on the board
I'd rather not trade
I want to play 95.
95 is okay
allows a trade but then D file opens
there's also the process Prospect of
getting the pawn to E6
don't start with this
they have takes I take with Pawn
for
having flashbacks to my games with Levy
some similar lines
probably B3
and this idea
uh oh
I have Knight G5 thankfully
G4 first
and you have Bishop H4
hmm
tension is building
finally winning upon
maybe H5 at some point
a confusing move
takes Knight C6
it takes her first
okay
foreign
still looks good
just time lies it's It's Tricky
hmm
foreign
also tying down the Queen's F7
a very forcing trade
thank you
I can get to D5
it should be winning
okay August 2500.
okay
back to tournaments
got berserk win on a streak that's five
tournament points
I'm realizing I have to try and just
make the most of every game
I think you exercise vid
A Gifted sub
I'm gonna stick with my main laborator
okay
very strange move Knight E6
there's already some plan Knight D5
threading this it's a nasty threat
I don't know how luck effectively deals
with it before
I have a five now
this gets pretty nice
it's important my night defends things
those Pawn attacks I think
no it's super simple though
in Bishop C1 first
ensuring that the queen can't access the
checking squares
and queen A4
I mean there's a really funny line where
I play this this and take and even the
bishop with Chuck
okay
I could take the Rook
I should take the Rook
I could also throw in the check actually
ensuring that there's no Bishop takes
Rook
so I'm the only one winning a rook also
have E5 here but
okay this looks pretty good
so I want a full Rook
I'm gonna play E5
I think it's better just to hunker down
three
Queen side castling
it's actually still not over like vlog's
gonna fight I'm gonna lose a night
I'm losing the pawn too it's really not
over
remind me later
wait a minute
I'm I'm still up a rook
you saw material I'm up a rook for a
pawn
so I was up a night in The Rook for Pawn
I was playing this position thinking I'm
only off the exchange
I have one more even more material than
I thought
okay
and now it's just an issue of uh moving
quickly
and it's a late stage hallucinations of
this tournament
I just want to simplify
this should be a pretty simple
conversion
um
ensuring that I can't easily Escape
offering the trade
Knight Defender Rook so Knight T3
doesn't quite work
okay 24.50
23.54 okay
okay that was a nice game
hey top 100 let's go
okay
I'm trying to satisfy the Believers
we can see the
prediction results from a little bit
earlier
uh let me try and get into the top 80
now so next next goal
staff or Gambit time
okay stop for grab a Time
but I'm not sure how many points are
needed for top 50.
probably a lot
yeah well it's a little bit passive here
I mean we'll probably see this stuff
thinking my knight should maneuver
do I need to defend
that's so tempting to take on E2
although Queens are starting each other
okay so I'll take we'll keep a
positional
and then
this and this
is F1 coming
yeah I feel like I missed some
opportunity
it's still not bad for black I mean
still should be slightly better
double Pawns
and just requires patience now
Rook da coming
soon
trying to identify the ideal sell-up
don't mind the trade
okay now Rook D4 in some cases once the
Knight moves
maybe Rook D4 right away
also take actually let's take
and then this
simple chess
Rook D4 is on on the horizon
that's a good move
your D4 Rook B6
oh
I'm allowing takes takes and then takes
no that doesn't work at all Rook d8
but there is back right made potential
like my Bishop's pins in the meetings
where
and I can't immediately take here
okay everything B5 now
if I play B5 last move there is Rook
check
which may have also still been fine for
me
now I just take
yeah now now I have to convert the
ending
up a pond but I'm down a lot of time
oh 50th Place have has 330 points
yeah that's gonna be hard to catch
I just gotta take them one game at a
time
let's move first
I'm trading a little bit
and there's not too many ways to defend
the pawn
that's annoying
my king is close enough
foreign
foreign
[Music]
ah
oh I hung a rook
oh that's so sad
love 2500.
23.87 what to do
okay
There Goes My streak too
yeah the tricky ending to convert
um
yeah I came down to some critical
moments towards the end
foreign
[Music]
spots so
yeah I mean I have to
have to work to like stay in in top
hundred or get back to top hundred
yeah this is a
topical line
had this line a while ago
idea Rook A2
wait a minute I just messed this up
I just messed this up what did I do
I completely botched the opening
uh I should probably resign
once once the blocking gets safe I'll
resign
how did this happen
I thought I was playing the theory
oh I'm supposed to just take the Knight
yeah black played like some I resign
uh what to do
it's supposed to take the Knight there
there's another line where white should
play Rook A2
okay
let me try and recover
it's a long tournament
um okay I'll play some standard
opening
yeah that was the case it wasn't really
a mouse slip it was just a matter of
me playing automatically and not
realizing what exactly the line was
but now um yeah now we have a London
uh Queen C2
Knight H5
this is mid lays line
I think I'm supposed to take and then E5
I preferred this a while ago
specifically for minlay
I do leave the pawn hanging but light
can't take it because
the two would fall on the end
I know E4 is a move wow
so white calling my bluff
I don't think I was bluffing though
I mean there's a few checks like one
more check
do most ducks live in
[Music]
um
I don't know
uh South Dakota
I like how the TTS pronounce that too
emphasis on the duck
in this move
actually I can just take well let's not
be too careless
I just have to play a few more accurate
moves
Bishop D6
actually I think Bishop D6
giving away the pawn then kingsy Saturn
like The Rook is still trapped
quackifornia
[Music]
can can ducky
new ducksico
oh
Arkin duck
I think the best try no 983 just walks
into Queens E3
duck Sylvania
[Music]
duck
foreign
I'm guessing 1900.
oh
If I decline then it should provoke
resignation right
okay
hey 1900 was not too far off
okay
uh trying to inch my way back
I'll let E4
I feel like being aggressive here
no more London
I'll have Knight C3 Sicilian
Grand Prix attack
yeah earlier I played D4 like out of
some
a freak accident
this hangs upon
you still have five isn't it the idea
I could take
might as well just take
D6 is coming so let's play this first
then G4
and then this
okay I'm going to try and get my heart
rate below 60 this game
this game might be over soon though
I'm just trying to relax
meditate a little bit
yeah now it's completely restricted by
the bishop
hmm B4 looks nice
oh no my heart rate I broke 70.
it's hard to try hard to relax
it's kind of like counterintuitive
[Music]
um
what's my plan maybe this
open file if takes is made in one
oh
wait this is not so simple oh no I just
I completely messed up
I can't prevent the triple Fork
although maybe I can play like King
how to do this
ah I'm gonna lose this game
[Music]
I mean this should be a draw opponent
might go for a dirty fog
okay back to tournaments
99th Place at least I didn't lose that
uh I have to stay awake
we are finally in the final hour of the
tournament
oops
okay Zen Mode's off
I guess for the final hour I'll know who
I'm playing
back to the London
London is nice for Blitz because
most lines I'm prepared pretty deeply so
it doesn't require mental energy to play
the first several moves
but it still requires a little bit as we
saw from that uh
that one previous game
A4 would be a battery move
foreign
being very aggressive here
I think I can get away with taking
looks risky but
and defend the knights
I know he was almost trapped
now Rook cheer I take on e4
so I'm up upon
I'm losing a bond back
I'm not so proud of what I've done here
really not a problem
that's still equal material
turning this
okay
Bishop supports the pawn
along with a rook Rook F5 is the main
idea
I don't want to trade
uh this is winning now
or is it
still good winning chances
uh let's play this
oh wow
good move
foreign
okay back to tournaments
97th
I'm taking a risk here
yeah we're having a um
pretty classic anti-london
you believe ins quack
uh the quacks never stop
my H4 interesting
I think I'll preserve the bishop
starting this
a pretty simple plan now
yeah this gets weird
[Music]
um
let's go for this I'm not sure if this
works
point is after it takes I play Knight B3
yeah so I still lost a pawn but I have
the bishop pair
this Pawn's a bit weak
[Music]
um
Brooke
for this I don't did not know what to
play there
I should play Rook here and then set up
uh Bishop C2 Bishop B3
couldn't move uh this triple Fork thing
again
and it's still a playable
idea Rook C3
let's play H4 if I get the chance
have to take
so this not only attacks the pawn but It
prepares for C8 twitch baby
hey it's tokoroku thank you choco
uh let's play this
holding on
Rook C8 Rook C2
on this Rook G2
I'm pretty move Rook G2 though
our Rook G2 I think was winning easy win
two
wow really
less than three
let's go
let's go okay
oh
so when I when I pre-moved uh H1 green I
thought it was made no matter what and
then Bishop F1 happens
and then I
I wasn't ready for that I should play
this move
oh okay let's go
hey it's Bach what's up Bach shout out
to Bach
okay
top 100
almost 300 tournament points
41 minutes left
I was in big trouble that game
berserk continues
opponent opponent probably saw that last
game and was
slightly terrified
yeah what was my Peak heart rate this
stream
142 was definitely up there
yeah it's happened maybe a handful of
times my like opponents resign on move
one
and I have a feeling it's because
players
like they see that I'm much higher rated
and
they don't want to spend time playing
the game
which there should be some system in
place to
at least temporary man people who do
that
because it's not good for the
like the arena for players who
like resign on purpose to
just try and waiting to play Easier
opponents
but I assume leechas has a system in
like that in place
okay I'm gonna try and focus here
hmm
some sharp position incoming
um I'm probably losing some Pawn
or multiple Pawns
the queen E3 King B1
and then Rook T8
I might have to go into an end game
which
loses material too
I mean there's Knight C4
not so thrilled with the position
Knight D5 um
this is actually a really bad position
uh
I mean
this and then pray
Queen B3 first
foreign
yeah I'm already down the pond
that's interesting
can take
I'm losing a piece or not
or I'm just getting mated
wow what a mating sequence
crazy mating sequence
how far back was it for his mate
was like force made
after
I mean it was all losing yeah made in
six
opponent found it okay
moving on
so I have 300 tournament points
36 minutes left
I think I'm trying to finish shop 80
which is
at this point only six or seven
tournament points away
okay waiting for another game
oh playing for posse okay
Posse like avoided my stalemate trap
earlier
this is some funny line
a kind of unusual position
yeah that's a good move
I'm Bishop E5
so there's this pin
if I take
I think I'm losing a pawn or maybe not
but maybe
oops
yeah
it can be it
I think this and this
okay threatening this now
286 I take on E3
still take on E3
this now
don't hurt me
strange position
equal material
this move looks crushing but
I'm threading this
check
start with
starting with this
foreign
[Music]
does not work
that doesn't work
ah
the king's escaping
unfortunately
okay so let's move
Jack
I missed a fork
yeah like a game oh what a game
GG
uh
[Music]
I'll be right back
[Music]
one sec
okay
uh dessert I don't know if I should be
berserking at this point
hey it's Hannah what's up Hannah
okay playing a Budapest
I really haven't had too many Budapest
gambits this tournament
um this is a line where
like Bishop B4
King F2
I don't think I've seen King F2 before
that's interesting
am I losing a piece no
no I have this move
I'm getting a little bit squeezed though
I'll play this
yeah a little bit less space
what's the king doing on F3
opponents was trolling me okay let's
keep the king here
I want to play this and this
now if King F2 I have this
starting with this
okay that was just getting really weird
and there's almost some mating ideas
I'm looking at F5
but I mean Knight G4 coming looks nice
just trying to find the follow-up
I'm not seeing it
and this is the vessel I see
which might be good enough
I don't think my queen is getting
trapped
if Knight moves anywhere it's checkmate
if
okay that's a move
[Music]
I'm just says
looking at lines where I sack on G5
that's playable now
take
hmm
foreign
[Music]
oh no my queen
foreign
idea
this doesn't work
I'm just down a full Queen
for two pawns for two Pawns
and winning back some material so if
this I fork and of the site Fork oh
that's so funny
oh this is less funny
oh no my forking potential
let's play this
what a crazy game
I'm in trouble now
yeah no sale Matrix unfortunately
oh what to do
I had ideas I was
for some reason I was calculating takes
and then Rook A3 I had to take the queen
verse of course
and then there's some mating ideas
okay
98th Place it's gonna be a struggle to
say in the top hundred
I still have I have three losses on a
row oh no
okay 22 minutes left that's time for
what three games maybe four five
okay try and finish strong
okay another one of these opponents
I mean leeches should like
leeches should probably have stricter
measures during Marathon tournaments
because I think there's some measure
where if you
if you purposely resign like some X
number of games it will temporary
temporarily ban you
but in these tournaments it should be at
least like maybe maximum two games
okay I played this opponent once before
and lost
okay this is a fun line
this is a line I've I played a handful
of
times
since discovering it
the idea is if the Knight moves back I
take on D6 because of the PIN
and we're gonna see something similar
here
yeah this is already winning it takes
takes takes and then checkmates
also B5 is hanging
um
I mean everything is winning here I
think this is probably the most precise
ensuring F6 uh would get muted
it's not quite neat
it's something it's good enough okay
a nice game
I use that line to beat midlay
uh mid lane survived for 14 moves
okay top 90.
okay 80th Place is Within Reach
trying to get on the streak again
[Music]
that's frustrating
I mean it's free tournament points but
people should not be abusing the system
like that
I'm I'm legitimately a little bit
frustrated
how do I
how do I release all my rage
I think this is something for Lee chess
developers to do
um
for
Marathon tournament specifically
is to ensure people don't like just
resign against stronger players and then
get away with it
okay
uh oh playing Mr Ducky
Mr Dougie
where's my duck
I've been playing so much normal chess
recently I forgot about duck chess
I like this position
I'll Target the pawn
yeah it's um
it's gonna be a positional grind
I want to make this move work but
it doesn't quite work
C5 is a nice break
if I can take take and then win F4
um
I'll take
I have Knight takes I think I get away
with this
although it's
kind of unclear
so if takes I take
if it takes there is check
but there's also Rook D7
yeah this is Pleasant
and all I have to do is not get muted
easier said than done
wait let's not plunger a rook
oh it's been a long tournament
yeah we'll treat Queens
okay
defeated Mr Ducky
hey top 80s okay
can I make it to top 50 now
trying to finish strong
50
is still kind of far away 342.
[Music]
that's pretty far away
I would need at least five more games
now at least six more games okay
this is a start
okay I'll play the sign
ah this is opponent that played really
aggressively
so I'm gonna play aggressive back
oops oh no
and by aggressive I mean blunder all my
Pawns
somehow it's paying off I'm winning the
night
black will have three pawns for it maybe
for if this move no I take the night I
defend each four
this is pretty solid
okay
okay top 70.
moving up in the world 13 more minutes
so how many more games I mean
technically there's only time for like
two more games if they go the full
distance
realistically probably three or four
more games
ideally like 10 more games
okay England got the time
this opening worked earlier
aggressive play
we might trade Queens
uh
it's actually not too bad I'm only
losing the exchange
not ideal though
opponents in 70 first place
I'm gonna try and fight
good move
never resign when you have a knight
there's actually a trial like if Rook D5
never mind
so I'm down the exchange and the pawn
so there's Fork potential
Rook H2
and I don't know how tired my opponent
is
I don't even know how tired I am
that's a great move by the way
[Music]
I have to play this really sad move
on B6
I want to do something active
foreign
yeah very instructive way to
win the game
I'll play on because you never know
I'll start with G6
I've seen crazier things happen
I could move
okay I resigns
well played
okay
[Music]
um
less than nine minutes
I'm really gonna try and finish strong
uh and hopefully not finish on a loss
opponent played about that game playing
bordovi pione
okay there should be time for two more
games
double berserk
we have a fog beer counter gamut
so a lot of geometry here
wow
trying to route my mind around this move
um
probably Bishop F5
keeping some tension
yeah the dream is to checkmate
or it's a castle mate
I play this move
that's a bit too much actually
I think this is playable
if Queen Jake's like Castle
and if takes I play Rook d8
okay it's getting spicy
what surprise for first place
uh you just got like a trophy on your
profile there's no monetary prize
okay
doing pretty nice
top 70.
I think there's also virtual trophies
for like top 100 top 50 top
[Music]
we've reached the point where everyone's
been working
on E6 wasn't pre-moved
so this is another wall scanned
uh we'll play H4
defending with a rook
okay let's just make this game weird
lifting both the Rooks
we'll keep some Central tension
the king will stay in the center
I'm definitely not casting this game
uh let's play this move
F4 and then the other Rook can lift over
this is maybe a playable move
but then it gets really spicy
okay both Rooks doing stuff
Queen also wants to do stuff
Wendy no
oh this Rook is hanging what
I have to play this
ensuring that if takes I take here
so I'm down a piece but this works the
target
I take and defend
What's Happening Here
the king is just literally sitting
watching all the madness
let's developing night
let's play this move first
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm in trouble
foreign
okay at least I'm turning a triple Fork
um
and
I was looking for the stalemate setup I
think pairings were closed right
oh no the finish the tournament
okay I still finished top 80. 71st
that's it
the 2022 Autumn Marathon the final 50
seconds
over 23
500 players
twenty three five five three five five
four
is it possible to join with 30 seconds
left
if you could join but you probably won't
be paired
anyway thanks everyone for tuning in
I appreciate those that
helps keep me awake
gave me some energy
blue pigment
now it's time for duck chess yeah
time for a 24-hour duck chat stream
except not right now
I'm tired it's time for food
good job to the top finishers
good job to everyone who played
entitled players out there in Chicago
wow jigako like joining late it seemed
like
played
played 130 games compared to
368 games
how many games have I play
Ed 110 games
only played 110 games
wow
will this be on YouTube
yeah why not I'll put this on YouTube
sometimes with the marathon videos they
take a long time to like download and
then edit export
but
um assuming this goes on YouTube
let me know that you made it this far
let me know your favorite game
leave timestamps in the comments leave a
smile in the comments
and stay tuned for more content
thanks for an awesome day of chess